Ron DeSantis donors are set to meet with
him to discuss the viability of his
campaign as reported this is a reporting
coming out of Fox Business they're
concerned that his polls are lagging and
they want to see some improvement and
we're also hearing rumors that uh we
have also somewhat corroborated but keep
in mind these are rumors that a Super
PAC working Fortis is seeing people
abandon the campaign so we're going to
talk about that and where does Santa's
currently is in the polls this is the
big story that's been been breaking all
day whether or not uh he's going his
campaign's going to be viable I mean
it's it's still really really early to
say but I think it's interesting
considering what's going on politically
and then we're going to talk about uh
this one's fascinating Ray Epps is suing
Fox News
okay that one's interesting I think
discovery on that one will be very
fascinating and then of course FBI
director Ray is getting grilled by
members of Congress and Matt Gates
called him out for protecting the Biden
family this one should get pretty
interesting before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com to buy
cast Brew Coffee to help fight those
commies uh well actually just support us
in the work that we do but kind of right
Casper coffee is our coffee company some
of the best coffee if not the best
coffee you will ever had ever ever have
you can buy the rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend Appalachian nights or
join the coffee club and get three bags
every single month and uh it comes in
ground or whole bean your choice
Supporting Cast Brew Coffee buying
coffee from us is how you support the
show or you can go to timcast.com click
become a member do I have this one
pulled up here we go click join us
become a member to support our
journalists and the work we do directly
and we're going to have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight at about 10 or so p.m so you
don't want to miss it and as a member if
you've been signed up for at least six
months or you signed up the 25 per month
level you can actually call into the
show and ask us questions so it's going
to be a good one joining us tonight to
talk about this and a whole lot more is
Jamie Michelle hi great to be here
thanks for having me back I was here
December but it's been a while it's good
to be on the show with you guys who are
you and what do you do I am the founder
president CEO of the non-profit gays
against groomers uh we fight groomers
from inside the community
we are fighting the sexualization
indoctrination and medicalization of
Youth uh that is being perpetrated under
the guise of lgbtqia plus plus plus plus
uh and yeah things are heating up in
this war but I think we're going to win
at the end and I'm just excited to talk
about it well right now well thanks for
joining us we got Dole shimcast here my
name is Seamus Coughlin I have YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we make
animated cartoons we're going to be
releasing one tomorrow about uh the
sound of freedom and the controversy
surrounding that with certain activists
and critics in Hollywood who aren't
happy with the film so I want to
encourage you all to check that video
out it's going to be a little bit spicy
and if you want to support what I'm
doing go to freedomtunes.com to become a
member and also uh sign of freedom is
number one sound of freedom is another
story as it should be it's not a
professional because I deserve it I went
out Ian Crossing what's up I went that
took the last night off because I went
to see sound of Freedom it was awesome
what's up Brandon I saw you at the
theater good to see we didn't talk
afterwards
um wow what a powerful movie I haven't
seen it yet but I'm really excited me
and my fiance were supposed to see it
last weekend but things got really busy
but I've obviously only heard amazing
things yeah I cried a couple times I'm
sure it's gonna absolutely destroy me
I'm a little nervous for that but it has
to be seen in a good way it's like it's
like a reach it breaks you down and then
builds you back up kind of as a new
person it's so powerful it got me to
look outside myself it's sad though
because it's a true story and like
there's a million other stories just
like that you know happening right now
well you know all of this stuff yeah
exactly you're exactly right this is
going on in the world today human
trafficking is a massive problem as the
film points out the United States of
America is one of the largest consumers
on the planet of basically slaves of
this sort yeah
explicit yeah yeah exactly why is
Hollywood so upset about this film we're
gonna do it yeah we also got this man
over to the right yeah I'm excited to
see it too I'll be watching it uh
tomorrow alone Sheamus like I said which
is fine so we always see movies yeah I
never see movies at all so I'm excited
to be in the theater uh let's do this
when you're out of town but I do have an
announcement to make and I know a lot of
you are going to be saddened to hear
this but um it's all we could do uh this
weekend I will be flying out of state
because I have to get hip surgery I am a
37 year old lifelong skateboard I've
been skating for like 23 or so years so
I have a repetitive Sports industry
presumably
uh injury and we I don't know we don't
know exactly what it is it may be a tear
but the idea is take care of it now so
it doesn't get worse you don't gotta get
hair replacement which means I'm gonna
be gone for a week but uh I know it's
gonna I'm I can't believe I have to do
this to you guys you're gonna get really
mad you're gonna get really mad hate
mail Sheamus is going to be hosting that
right it's going to be the best
week of Tim cast or should I say
shimcast that you've ever seen we wish
we wish Tim well we wished him well by
the way you're welcome for agreeing to
take over your podcast for a whole week
and keep it going and ensure that things
stay on the rails he insults me you
accuse me of stealing your spoons you
insult me in front of your audience
after I agree to help you with your show
like what am I doing here did you return
the spoons I didn't I I don't agree with
your framing I don't agree with your
framing I don't appreciate it okay but
but also is it it it does suck you know
because I I'm like talking with the
doctor
and the general issue is
do this sporadic like do this randomly
over the next several months where it's
like I'll randomly take days off and
it'll be very disruptive and hard to
plan or just do one solid week where we
get it all taken care of and then come
back and it's done and I've got to deal
with that ever again so it's it's soft
tissue damage it's not going to heal on
its own and uh fortunately there are
Advanced procedures for taking care of
it so it's magnificent just means that
I'll have to be like in a hospital for a
week who's gonna look after the chickens
we gotta have to do everything I'm
literally a replacement Tim while he's
gone I'm not wearing a beanie I'm gonna
destroy everything yeah yeah just James
all right let's talk about the news what
else here's a story from CNBC DeSantis
donors privately worry about campaign as
Florida Governor lags in 2024 polls they
say some of ratatus's fundraisers have
recently heard concerns up from donors
about the trajectory of his campaign the
governor continues to lag Trump in GOP
Primary polls Ken Griffin the
billionaire CEO of Citadel and previous
Santa's Mega donor continues to assess
the field a growing excuse me group of
donors who have supported desantis's run
are worried about the trajectory of his
campaign even after he raked in 20
million dollars despite those big
fundraising numbers and his entry into
the race on a wave of hype DeSantis is
lagging well behind front-runner Donald
Trump
so they're going to basically make a lot
of the same points nothing's changed and
Griffin's stance toward the election we
have this from the post-millennial they
say DeSantis to meet with major donors
to face questions about campaign
viability this is coming from Charles
gasparino Fox Business Rhonda said is
planning to meet major East Coast owners
next week at a private gathering in
Southampton he faces questions about
viability of his campaign as he stalled
in the polls I hear he's planning to
tell donors that he will play the long
game and to uh just uh bring in the
context in terms of data the prediction
markets now have Ronda Sanders dropping
down to 19 cents to Donald Trump's 62
cents and this is big because DeSantis
actually surpassed Trump at one point
but now continues to fall and the latest
poll from morning consult shows
nationally DeSantis is actually doing
worse than Trump though both Trump and
attendants do lose to Joe Biden I'm not
sure I believe that both of them will
lose to Joe Biden but if we're talking
about comparing Trump and DeSantis in
the same metric to Biden then it looks
like Trump is still ahead of Rhonda
santis and DeSantis has been uh dropping
in the polls so I don't know what you
guys think it is it is still really
really early really early really early
really really early it's like six weeks
into the campaign right I mean he
launched like what six not even really
how long it feels like it's been going
on for a long time yeah I mean look look
that's what I'm saying it's like a week
in politics is like a freaking year you
know it's like that's also true but I
think especially like a week with
respect to his campaign things have gone
so South in so many ways there's a lot
about DeSantis and I've said this before
there's a lot about him I like I think
and there's even people on his campaign
who I know and like but I think some of
the people making decisions there could
have been more wisely chosen
yeah I mean I I don't know anything
about the people there no I understand I
don't respect how his campaign is active
no yeah there's been a lot of blunders
yeah I understand that and I I you know
whatever whoever has a team around them
like whatever candidate has a team I
don't think that that's reflective of
the way that the actual candidate could
lead I'm still like super pro DeSantis I
think it is incredibly early I'm proud
to santis for many reasons I choose him
over Trump for many many reasons and we
can get into that if you guys are
interested but uh I think it's
incredibly early and yeah I don't think
things have really even gotten started I
mean we're we have the debates in August
we have this new town hall coming up
with Tucker
um and I think he's going to get the
message seven weeks yeah yeah what's the
town hall of uh I think it was
just announced that Tucker is hosting
like a town I don't know if it's I don't
think it's a debate it's a town hall
with like all of the Republican or uh
candidates except for Donald Trump I
don't know he's not going Trump's
pulling a Biden did he well did he did
he say Trump is running from the
basement I mean it's you know yeah so um
I think again I think that there have
been a number of like strategic blunders
from the the DeSantis campaign you are
correct that it's very early these I
mean it's like eight months away yeah
exactly we have quite a lot of time
um I I do think that the DeSantis
campaign is probably going to have to
rethink some of what they're doing and
we'll see how this meeting with the
donors go but yeah it's going to be a
little while before we can definitively
say this person is more or less likely
to get the nomination I've got a
projection I think that Ron is not going
to be able to match vivex energy and by
the time three four months from now
those numbers will be FL I don't know if
this is actually going to happen those
numbers will be flipped yeah I know the
bank is at 10 cents in the prediction
Market that's up from nine from like
five seconds from one minute ago from
about 10 minutes ago is at nine it's
jumped up again and within the past he
Vivek has only been a viable contract on
predict it for about a week and a half
uh let's just say two weeks to be fair
and now he's up to uh 10 cents from
three
I think I think the thing about Vivek is
that he doesn't have anything behind him
in terms of uh notability I'm not saying
that career-wise like obviously he's
like worth half a billion dollars on
this big pharmaceutical company what I
mean is Rhonda Santos has been in the
Limelight for years and has a proven
track record out of Florida Vivek has
the words he has he the words he can say
he was kind of like what he's saying and
he is masterfully tactful in terms of PR
I think that's going to help the vague I
got to be honest though as much as I
like Vivek and think he's the smartest
guy in the room
in terms of capability I will say this I
put Vivek over Trump and DeSantis in
terms of electability it's Trump
DeSantis Vivek like Vivek is is great
but even Rhonda Sanders I think is is
more viable of a candidate than he is
it's true I think you're right and a lot
of times when I play video games and I'm
like I get to select who the leader is
going to be among all of my generals
I'll take the one with the best stats
not necessarily the most most famous one
but in reality it's a popularity contest
so the famous person gets into the power
but when you put the best person in
control even if there are nobody you get
the best results I gotta be completely
honest I have not heard a single thing
from his campaign like I I haven't seen
any tweets I I mean I don't even I may
follow him I'm not sure yeah I've heard
and seen nothing you're in a bubble no
I'm not in a bubble I'm very involved
everything like I I mean you know I'm
not tapped into different news sites
like you are but like I'm part of the
conversation and the dialogue and I'm
not you know I follow a lot of people
but the diverse people that but no but I
think you make a good point too yeah
exactly
broken out into this space
is not there yet I've seen exactly and I
agree with you I've seen a lot of clips
of him uh floating around I've seen
different public statements he's made I
haven't noticed anything specifically
from his campaign I saw him beach in
Miami with like a Trump's uh when Trump
was getting indicted you know he went
down and he was speaking at a Podium
um and that's the last I saw of him so I
I think he's sucking up to Trump a
little uh no Vivek are you kidding yeah
he's a hardcore Trumper yeah I've I've
interviewed him multiple times I mean
I'm saying perception Wise from the
outside that's I mean she literally went
down to Miami and gave a huge speech
like you know uh in support of trump
yeah obviously because of the false
indictments yeah I think it's a little
bit different from being a Trumper
though I agree I agree but I think you
know he he continuously Praises Trump I
mean because he he understands that you
can't lose that base right or he's
scared of it he's scared to lose the
cult base I think that's the
magedonians I think that's unwarded
Vivek is is in in my
yeah I think so too Vivek outright said
he thinks there should be Civic
requirements for voting and he and he's
sitting here in this room and he's like
man maybe they're gonna get mad at me if
I say this but I'm gonna say it because
we need to like there's got to be some
restriction some requirement for civic
duty brilliant idea I actually do who's
got the balls to actually say that so
what he does did then was he came out
and said okay I've refined my ideas I
think young people should pass a Civics
test if they want to vote and it's just
like wow like that's a bold thing to say
who writes the test I think you might
ask them that question yeah right for
sure when it came to an impact wow
that's why I think signing up for the
selective service was like the smart
compromise men and women have the option
to do it if you don't sign up you don't
vote if you do sign up you can vote but
that makes you eligible for the draft
the draft almost never happens or it's
not likely to happen so it's like it's a
it's a it's a clever workaround and uh
but but that is just one issue where if
you actually watch him give talks and
speeches and stuff
he won't run away from questions until
he watches him I don't see him anywhere
well just I mean that's why he's in
third place right no and not but I mean
I'm not I'm saying like that he he has
some good ideas I'm not knocking that at
all I'm just saying I mean to think that
he's a serious candidate right now in
this race is silly and like I mean but
you know it is it it is incredible third
place it's yeah but come on now Vivek
right now on YouTube following third
place as well and like I said you know
it is super early we have no idea what
the campaign's gonna look like in a
month or the the primary is going to
look like in a month two months I didn't
say that Ted Cruz win like the first
battle Battleground state in the 2016
primaries or whatever like Ted Cruz won
something or something and then everyone
was like oh it's you know Trump ended up
turning things around I think that with
Vivek that the global economic order is
very concerned about him getting into
Power because he's straight up like
we're not investing in BlackRock anymore
we're taking our money and we're
investing in American indexes we're
gonna get away from ESG we're gonna take
control of our financial system and
that's like the main force of control
Global protection press is the financial
system they want Central Bank digital
currencies and they want to be able to
turn your bank account off if you don't
if you want to buy things they don't
want you to buy if you say something
they don't want you to say they did it
with the Canadian truckers and I think
Vivek is he's so smart and he's he knows
when to talk and when not to talk that
being said I think that's a big part of
the reason why the media hasn't propped
them up at all they haven't propped up
really any of the the Republican
candidates I think they're propping
Trump up you think so I think so I think
in liberal media I think that the I mean
this is a little conspiratorial but it's
my theory I think that they are
Prosecuting him right now to bump his
numbers up because they want him to be
the nominee the Democrats desperately
want Trump to be the nominee and they
say it they say it all the time there
were just some clips that uh went out on
I think it was MSNBC where they're
saying you know they they want Trump to
be the nominee they're salivating over
it um
The View she was like we don't want to
send us we can beat Trump right of
course they can yeah that was also true
in 2016 the Clinton campaign engaged in
the Pied Piper strategy they wanted
Trump to be the nominee but then look
how that worked out for right yeah yeah
they're much more scared of DeSantis at
this point I don't think so with that
Georgia Democrat who just uh defected
and joined to the GOP good for her yeah
I I don't I don't I don't believe them
when they're like or or I don't believe
they're correct when they're like we
should have Donald Trump because we can
beat we can beat him but we can't beat
DeSantis I mean yeah okay we like look
it's 50 50 right now Trump lost 2020 he
won 2016. I'm not convinced the Pied
Piper strategy is their path and all of
his endorsed candidates not all but most
of them the big ones lost in the
midterms I mean we're on a loot huh who
in the midterms most of trump scanners
yeah I mean Herschel Oz Lake
um you know off the top of my head what
was the actual number like thing was a
travesty I mean yeah but I'm just saying
like we're on a serious losing streak
with this Trump guy what do you think
about Robert F Kennedy things RFK Jr
what do you think
um I think he's you know I think it's
interesting I love that he's giving 82
success rate 82 percent of Trump's
endorse candidates won
okay and we still have we we lost
everything at the end of the day we lost
the major seats that were the most
important to re to gain you know but but
I think sometimes a failure of messaging
on the part of the Republican party I'm
just directly addressing what you said
about Trump's endorsements the 82 that's
fine but at the same time the major ones
that he put the most effort into that he
campaigned with that he pushed the
hardest you know the big National names
the national recognition he screwed up
with us that was a big I have no idea
why he would make that thing that's
crazy should have been Kathy Barnett I
mean she was absolutely incredible and I
mean this is the thing Trump continues
to you know he says he's going to drain
the swamp but then he he I mean Lindsey
Graham let's hear how you hear about how
you feel about this Lindsey Graham on
stage with him in South Carolina you
know he got booed a million times but
but how is Trump going to drain the
swamp when he's best friends with the
swamp he hired the swamp he's going to
continue to do that like I guess we vote
RFK then huh yeah I'm going to uh I will
I'll register
I want to hear an answer to that though
like I want to hear an answer to that
how is Trump gonna drain the swamp when
he is best friends with the swamp how
like if DeSantis got on a stage with
Lindsey Graham and and Lindsey Graham
opened for DeSantis what would happen
What would the Trump people online I
don't I don't think you should go down
this route because DeSantis is funded by
Griffin I'm see now you're changing the
subject though I'm literally saying if
you're gonna if you're gonna ask
questions about Trump being started by
bad people which I agree with the same
is true for Descendants so my point
being Vivek Rama Swami must be our guy
okay no but I'm I'm trying to say like
what is it how how do people think that
Trump is the anti-establishment
candidate when he literally is
campaigning with Lindsey Graham like a
week ago we could I don't even remember
I think what the hell is yeah it's never
wrong I know I know well no that's not a
trump has made a lot of mistakes and
I'll acknowledge them but what I would
say as far as the the candidates go
right now Trump has the largest
incentive to be the most
anti-establishment candidate possible
because of what the Deep State and
three-letter agencies did to him they
did it while he was President too though
yeah no that's my point that is when
they did what they did and now he's
pretty substantially angry about what
they did of course they did it while he
was President right but and he was also
concerned about re-election and he also
had weights around his ankles because of
what the Deep state was doing to him so
yes that did limit his ability to act
that Trump Trump's first thing is that's
not what I said no but you're straw mad
at me because I specifically said he's
made mistakes no and I'm saying there's
reason to believe that he would be
interested in fighting considering what
they've done campaigning with Lindsey
Graham what the hell is that like how
can you can't have it both ways yeah
that's really bad he shouldn't yeah
say that I and I've said this before I
think people he's chosen to surround
himself with have not been great picks
but I'm saying in terms of like the
drive and the interest in in draining
the swamp and going after these agencies
I think Trump has the strongest
incentive
uh I'm not saying there's no credibility
to that criticism by the way I think
Trump has uh historically made a lot of
mistakes with the with respect to the
people he surrounded himself with that
but I think he is more of a drive to
destroy the Deep State and uh I I do
think he has what it takes but we'll see
I don't know if that's necessarily true
that being wronged is the makes
straight up the best incentive like
anger is the best because I think Ron
DeSantis the incentive to make a better
country is is could be equally as strong
as instead of like they hurt me I want
to hurt them back he cares about but
it's all it's all of it right because
because they're both good motivations
now part of the advantage of another
Trump well
he would only yeah he would not have to
worry about re-election which is also a
massive massive asset wait say that
again right wait he would not have to
worry about reelection which is a
massive asset yeah if he was President
that's super detrimental to us as a
party though no that's it but but he
would go after but he would go after all
the people he needed to go prefer to
have somebody in the White House that
could fulfill eight years like so we're
not doing this again and risking the
White House again in another four years
you have to rest the why sorry for us
it's an election Trump can't run again
though like the incumbent
for you it would be his VP would
probably run right now or I mean I would
why would Ron and Don not run as
president vice president yeah
let's pull this up we got this from NBC
News Rhonda Santa says he wouldn't be
Trump's running mate I'm not a number
two guy can be though and then you'd be
the number one guy and then it was uh
Trump's campaign said he's not anybody's
guy I think that was Stephen Chung who
said that so yeah I mean that look the
the argument is Donald Trump did like a
c-plus job in a lot of areas in his
first term he didn't drain the swamp he
fired some people he hired some really
bad people but foreign policy wise I
think Trump did a very very good job
especially with the Abraham Accords uh
with trying to get our troops out of
Syria crushing Isis those things are
really great and then the argument now
is if we're looking at these two guys
Rhonda says and Donald Trump
there's one thing that I care about the
most I think foreign policy Wise It's
hard to know for sure Ronda Sanders has
some experience in foreign policy Donald
Trump has good foreign policy not
perfect foreign policy but better than
Obama better than Biden better than
whatever the Democrats have to offer the
question I have is who is more likely to
fire people
Donald Trump even if it's only by one
percent because he wants revenge and the
shift which has become obvious to me is
that when asked about the greatest
threat the country faces Trump said it's
not China which is a market shift from
where he was in his first and second
campaigns he said it's within this
country referring to bureaucrats working
for government who can't be fired so one
of the things Trump did near the end of
his term which he which was reversed by
the Democrats by Joe Biden was the
schedule F attempt you can't just fire
federal employees they're protected it's
very difficult so Trump was trying to
strip away at those protections to try
and start getting some of these people
fired I think Rhonda Santos because for
a few reasons it'll be his first term if
he does get elected and he is being
backed by some prominent establishment
figures is more likely to say let's
negotiate and figure out how we don't go
to war with each other I won't go around
firing and destroying everything but you
guys let me get some of these policies
through Donald Trump is more likely to
go and say I will fire everyone I will I
will nuke all of these bureaucrats and
agencies I would rather Donald Trump go
in and fire and clean house and then
four years from now be it DeSantis or
whoever else from Swami or you know
maybe some other libertarian I have no
idea someone can then come in without
these bureaucratic permanent government
individuals who have been in government
for 30 years without without being
elected those people have to be fired
the problem ask a question why didn't he
do it the first time Trump was trying to
negotiate it was a it was it sounds like
an excuse what does that mean give me an
argument I'm just saying like you know
there's always a reason why there's an
excuse for why Trump wasn't able to do
something in his first term it's
literally the explanation of what Trump
was doing Trump talked to Sheldon
adelstein he gets these big donors and
they're like listen we're gonna let you
do your thing but you got to play ball
with us and Trump says you got it boss
and then what ends up happening John
Bolton garbage that's what Rhonda
Sanders is doing right now with Ken
Griffin so my argument is Donald Trump
made a big mistake with these morons
that Rhonda Santa is doing right now
Trump is pissed off they screwed him
over and stabbed him in the back and is
more likely even if it is only two
percent to go in and try to fire these
people and just gut them from the system
whereas I see the Santos once again
meeting with big neocon donors and
playing the game that that Trump was
playing first time around
Trump was funded by big Pharma I mean
they donated to his campaign you know so
it's like I I don't know you're making
my argument that's that's my point right
so I don't know who these establishment
people are there
okay
you know everybody says that that uh
that um sorry DeSantis is endorsed by
you know Paul Ryan and he's Jeb Bush 2.0
and all this stuff and I see absolutely
zero evidence when really well the Jeb
Bush thing is dumb I mean the whole
thing is absolutely stupid Trump
endorsed Paul Ryan Trump endorsed John
McCain I mean yes I I don't understand
how they can use it that was tax again
eight years ago okay I think Paul was
bad and I did not vote for Trump in
2016. good I mean and so now and that's
the thing I wanna I wanna stress for
people that don't know who I am or don't
know my position I am a two-time trump
voter I voted for him in 2016. I voted
for him in 2020 even though I was off
the Trump train uh you know into the in
the covet years because he subsidized
the presidency to fauci and um you do
sound like a two-timer trump voter I was
you just said something I fully agree
with I was I was Hardcore too I ran I
was making up two timers
if Trump would have gone in fire change
your support
giving you a hard time I understand who
would he replace them with is my concern
because he did not make a personal
choice if he went in and were to fire a
bunch of people who would he replace
them with Trump yeah I don't I don't
have faith in him I think that he failed
in his first term by giving the country
away to the medical industry in the in
the last year commissioner and that's
another conversation completely his
family what are you doing giving your
family power bro I mean I voted for
Trump not Jared Kushner not fauci and
that's who I got I don't want nepotism
in the white house it's disgusting I
want talented well-situated people that
can do their job really really well that
may not even know each other that's what
I want and I got a man that went on a
vaccine tour for the last year and a
half in office pushing an experimental
clot shot sorry I don't know if I can
say that on YouTube well it was
experimental it is experimental and to
this day one of my the biggest reasons
why I no longer support this man is
because to this day he goes and praises
the damn vaccine and operation War warp
speed takes credit for all of it says
it's the greatest thing that ever
happened to mankind I mean one of them
you know he's he said he saved 500
million people with it or sorry maybe
it's 100 million I don't want to get
whatever I'm just saying a gigantic
amount of amount of people which is not
true and he has yet to take
responsibility for any of the adverse
reactions he doesn't even acknowledge
them and I think that's absolutely
disgusting and I I cannot support him
and I understand that the argument is
Ron DeSantis pushed it early on too
right Ron DeSantis at least can
understand that that was wrong and has
moved past it is now fighting against it
you know so I I just like Trump is has
such a big ego that he cannot take
responsibility for anything he ever did
wrong he just continues to double down
and it's disgusting the issue I take
with this the first thing is I'll say is
our obligatory just talk to a doctor
about what is right for you and make
sure you find a good and trustworthy
doctor because they do exist I know I'm
literally going to one next week because
I got to get surgery or whatever
but here's here's where I'm at
politically especially when it comes to
like RFK I don't agree with him on a lot
of the stuff he said especially the eua
stuff on Ivermectin and vaccines I just
there's a lot of people who adamantly
believe things because they choose to
believe them and they think they're
right about everything whereas my
positions are typically alike unless I
see something to a great degree that
like provides confirmation
there's not much I can really say about
it so you know we've had several debates
on this show I've debated several
leftist individuals and they'll ask me a
direct question about something
political I'll be like don't know
literally I have no why don't you have a
position on this when it comes to the
vax stuff I don't know that's why I
always I'm just like I don't know talk
to a doctor what I can say is Donald
Trump refuses to back down from this as
one of his major campaign victories what
we do know is that there was a judge I
think it was in New York who ruled that
the vaccine does not prevent
transmission of the virus and then later
on you end up with a bunch of news
outlets claiming that was fake news this
was a judge recently what is it the the
judge who gagged the Biden campaign on
censorship is I believe the same judge
who said that the vaccine was not
preventing transmission like so the
vaccine was like yeah the conspiracy
theorists crazy but the media the media
is then said the inverse so my point is
basically like I see these conflicting
and contradictory stories and then I
wonder why it is that people choose to
take a stance on something that is it's
very difficult to understand instead of
just saying like you know what honestly
I don't know I I don't know how you can
draw a conclusion on this one I'll give
you an example RFK talking about
Ivermectin I really for the life of me
even after sitting with Joe Rogan have
never been able to figure out how anyone
justifies their stance on Ivermectin
what did he say about Ivermectin RFK
said that the reason Ivermectin was
never approved was because it would end
the emergency use authorization for the
vaccines which is just logically
inconsistent they granted the EU way to
monoclonal antibodies if it were true
that there were alternative treatments
like Ivermectin hydroxychloroquine they
literally could have just given it an
eua people then make a money argument I
think Alex and I was arguing this that
because Ivermectin is so cheap they
didn't want to give it an EU and I say
make that argument I'm not making that
argument I'm literally saying for RFK Jr
to come out and be like that's the
reason they didn't approve it is because
they wanted to sell vaccines and they
needed the eua I'm like that doesn't
make sense I hear this kind of stuff all
the time and no one ever gives me a
legitimate answer so we talk about the
studies pertaining to Ivermectin we talk
about the studies here's what I'll just
say here's what I want to say about the
vaccine for instance it's it's my
problem with the vaccine has nothing to
do with whether or not anyone thinks
it's good or bad I don't know I can only
tell you make sure you trust your doctor
and there's a good one and there are
some good ones out there they're not
super expensive you just got to go to
the right places go to cities and you'll
find good doctors but the issue here is
government mandates of medication I'm
not going to see her make medical
arguments I have no idea Trump wants to
tout this as a major success Trump also
says the mandates were bad Rhonda
Sanders also says the mandates were bad
what am I supposed to argue how am I
supposed to have a conversation with
someone when they make a definitive
scientific statement on something that I
can read all these studies and I'm just
like well I have no I literally have no
idea I'm not a doctor well I can mention
just the news for instance reported
there's more data coming out about
people suffering from myocarditis which
is now confirmed for many of these
vaccines there are concerns around I
think one was Paul I think Johnson
Johnson may have been pulled But
ultimately like I am not making a Again
YouTube I'm making make any widespread
claims about all the vaccines my point
is there is data coming out but even
with this there is still the simple
statistical uh argument that
if you give if you mandate 400 million
doses of a vaccine don't be surprised if
you get a thousand news stories about
Adverse Events that does not mean there
is a higher density of Adverse Events it
does however suggest to the libertarian
point the government should not be
mandating medications to people which is
where I'm at
blaming Donald Trump for what Democrat
Governors did does nothing to convince
me of why I should vote for Rhonda
Sanders I'm not that's not what I did at
all I'm saying that he has never backed
down he continues to praise operation
warp speed and rushing the vaccine just
a few days ago uh or like sorry I am so
bad with time like I don't know if it
was a week ago two weeks ago yesterday
that's just the present Epoch like
things move so quickly and so strangely
you never know
let me just say one thing let me just
say one thing uh you know he was just
again saying how great it was that he
was saying it usually takes the FDA
between 5 and 12 years or nine and 12
years to get this out but he got it out
in nine months that's what it was in
nine months isn't that I mean that's not
something to brag about my point is
that's kind of bad my point is stuff
should be tested longer this isn't I'll
tell you exactly what my thoughts are on
this I don't think you actually care
what do you mean it makes no sense for
you to say these things to me because
you never like
I don't care yeah I don't think you care
at all really okay because I think that
my mom passed away because of it well
but but okay and that and that I'm sorry
to hear about your money I'm not trying
to bring that into it but like to say
that I don't care about what the vaccine
what the vaccine is doing to people I
know people that were injured after
taking this vaccine what do you mean I
don't care this isn't just a political
Point against Trump this is serious when
has anyone ever talked about the the
efficacy of of of testing criteria
okay but this was rushed into society
this was something that so if your
argument is authoritarianism and
government mandates I agree yeah if your
argument is the science was done wrong
I'm like when has anyone ever known
anything rushing it and bragging that he
rushed it without proper testing is a
problem and he continues to praise it
and double down and say that he saved
100 million people when that's not true
I just want him to take credit it would
impress me there's no factual basis
points for anything you're saying okay I
can't I can't find I can't make a
logical fact-based argument when you're
saying things that aren't rooted in what
do you mean Donald Trump says something
hyperbolic and nonsense you then argue
that his statement is factually untrue
but there's actually no data points one
way or the other okay so do you think
that it was a good thing to bypass the
FDA you know their standard practices
and rush out an experimental vaccine to
be forced on people and I'm not saying
he forced it I am not saying that I am
saying do you think it's a good idea to
take credit for something and and praise
that this is something you did as one of
the greatest achievements of mankind
seriously I don't know anything about
scientific criteria how things are done
so if someone comes to me and says I've
never researched this before in my life
I know literally nothing about how the
labs operate I know literally nothing
about bsl4 Laboratories therefore I
think what Trump did was wrong because I
all of a sudden have opinion on
something I've never researched before
I'm just like okay I this this doesn't
mean anything to me at all okay if there
if there's like hey look for most of our
Lives we've argued about whether or not
like what is appropriate for children we
have moral standards as to what we teach
kids and all of a sudden we're seeing an
escalation in these people bringing
these books into schools here's why I
think it's wrong there's data suggesting
that kids and then I'm like oh I totally
understand that something we have all
been a part of our whole lives is
expansion of civil rights arguments
about what the lines are the debate 10
years ago where they said that if we
legalize gay marriage it's going to
result in you know grooming and then the
left argued it wouldn't and now now that
it's happening that conservative saying
aha this proves that now I'm like I
don't think it does this is like over a
long period of time something directly
impacting Our Lives has been the subject
of major political debate and we have
opinions on it and now we're correlating
data points suggest we think one thing
is or isn't the vaccine stuff is all of
a sudden one day people had an opinion
on a scientific issue they know nothing
about
there's arguments to be made about why
the mandates are bad and why the
government shouldn't have a role in
mandating things but when people come
like
people come to me and say the science
was done bad I'll be like how should the
science have been done it should have
been done by these standards have you do
you know anything about those standards
did anyone ever like I can't I have
nothing to say it's fine I'm not going
to change your mind you're not going to
change mine I'm just saying in my
opinion that disgusts me about Donald
Trump I'm not blaming him for the
mandates I'm not blaming him for
lockdowns I'm not doing any of that I am
saying he subsidized the country to
fauci and he rushed the vaccine okay
whatever science you want to cite I
don't know that's how I feel you and
that and I think it's a lot of other
people feel that way too I don't know
and I've always found it strange for
instance I find my positions I sat down
no offense my position is is typically
always like if I don't know anything
about this thing I I don't know what I'm
supposed to say about it and I wonder
why it is that people become so like
animated by something they've never been
involved in before
I can understand being upset about the
world was kind of brought into being
involved in the vaccine when our lives
were you know that's a government
management I'm not relating that to
Trump not everything I say has to do
with Trump I'm I'm just saying like I'm
not saying the mandates too it was also
like fear campaigned by the media in a
lot of ways and pharmaceuticals are
making money and those things I all
completely understand by big Pharma to
bring him up again the government should
not mandate medications so not have the
authority to do so and there were a lot
of people who resisted that that I
totally understand but I don't
understand how someone's going to try
and make a scientific argument for which
they don't know enough about to use as
their moral position when you will
likely lose now that being said like you
know that hotel's RFK debate is
hilarious that he wouldn't do it and I
think he should and I actually disagree
with RFK and a lot of stuff as you can
clearly hear me saying my issue is
mainly you have you have a very clear
and obvious uh issue government mandated
medication for some reason the issue has
been shifted away from that and towards
the science was you know what it was it
was Anthony fauci mandated medication
that was signed off on by Donald Trump
trump I mean there is there's an Envy an
interview of fauci saying that Trump
never pushed back on him Trump never
denied anything that fauci recommended
you know that's why I say literally he
subsidized the presidency to fauci
during this time now the origins of
kovid totally messed up I don't I don't
claim to know all that stuff I'm just
saying I voted for Donald Trump I got
fauci and I got an experimental vaccine
rushed and I'm not blaming him for the
mandates as I said before but I'm sorry
like can you not can you not take the
position and just criticize Trump a
little bit and say it's not a good look
it's not something he should do to uh
continuously praise it and say that he
saved 100 million people and and take
credit for operation warp speed which
Rush did
these are opinions on issues of science
I have nobody I have no basis
I just watched this video from uh we are
watching a flat earther video downstairs
and it's really funny like not I'm not
trying to correlate people who have
questions about vaccines with flat
earthers I'm trying to make a point
about specifically arguments that were
made by some guy in the video not saying
the same thing the issue was the guy
kept saying things that he clearly had
no knowledge of because of how he felt
about them and I'm like that's the only
issue I take with it I've I've not
measured the curvature of the Earth or
anything like that but it is strange to
me when someone's like you know I've
never had anything to do with any of
this science before I've never tested
I've never studied it but here's my
thoughts on it and I feel strongly about
it and to me I'm just like I find that
very weird like I don't know how you
have a position on something you've
never experienced before never
researched before you just heard
repeated and all of a sudden you're like
I agree that's not true I didn't just
hear it repeated but look I I don't want
to spend the whole time talking about
vaccine can I can I just say one thing
firstly of course I'm very sorry for
your loss that's horrible
um it was yeah I'm really sorry
um and not not even speaking to the
Medical Science I can't verify or
confirm or deny any of the numbers you
put out there uh about the jail but I
will say that I would agree with you
that Trump's relationship with fauci and
the way he handled the lack the
lockdowns was probably one of if not the
greatest weak points of his
administration yeah I mean that's really
when my support for him started
dwindling
um you know I I'm I want to remind
everybody again I am a two-time trump
voter I I don't know if people know or
if you guys know but I run this account
or I did I'm not very active on it
anymore called the gay who strayed and I
started that in 2017 as a gay Trump
supporter like I wanted to show that all
Trump supporters weren't straight white
men that's literally why I created the
account you know and um I was an avid
Avid like hardcore Trump supporter I
mean I just posted on Twitter
um like a few nights ago I I was
involved in like stop the steel protests
in Milwaukee like I was wearing a trump
cape on the news or a flag as a cape
like I was one of those people it was
one of those crazy people and now I'm
out of it and I'm looking at it and I'm
seeing people still in raptured by him
and and it and I'm just like bro there's
one the one thing that well there's two
big things that have been the focal
point of my critiques and it's zealotry
and it's deception that's what I don't
like I don't like it when people can't
explain or or they can't like they have
a position on something without
justification people are allowed to do
that do it all the time I'm critical of
that yeah I I just I I want to ask you
something here just because so you were
you were a huge Trump supporter
um and I'm curious did you stop liking
him some because you were you were at
stop the steel rallies right you were
still clearly a fan of him after 2020.
um was this because of the the tragedy
in your own life or were there other
factors what what was the moment I guess
when you said I really don't like Trump
at all well uh was it what him and
DeSantis went to war with each other
okay what was that so like I said I did
vote for him in 2020 and I was part of
stop the steal because I did not want a
democrat in the white house obviously
Trump isn't I can say like Trump did
have good parts of his presidency yeah
obviously he is incredibly like miles
better than a Biden present you know so
and I do believe that there were
election irregularities
um who knows again not an election
expert like I'm not a you know science
expert I maybe I can't comment on it I
don't know but no my support was
dwindling then and then um after stop
the steal and after
um after January 6th what I saw happen
and people go there in support of him
and him abandon people when he said he's
going to go to the Capitol with them he
didn't go he basically set them up in a
giant honey pot situation I mean you
know it's just a really bad idea to tell
people to go to the Capitol I know he
said go peacefully and whatnot like 100
his words were fine but the fact that
all these people went there because of
him and then after that like that was
fine it was I I didn't think it was a
very smart thing to do but that was fine
but then afterwards how he abandoned
these political prisoners he completely
abandoned the j-6 prisoners who are I
believe are just in like a DC gitmo you
know he never talked about them for
after the like during the last couple
weeks of his presidency right I mean he
pardoned he pardoned uh Kodak Black
which was huge awesome
how many how many how many people got
directly arrested no I don't know but
I'm just saying I'm not saying that he
could have pardoned them I'm just saying
like you know afterwards when they were
going through this whole process he
didn't speak about them at all he really
stayed hush-hush because j6 was such a
big like controversial thing in the news
and um it looked bad for him to speak on
it you know and get involved but his his
most Ardent supporters were rotting away
um in solitary confinement while you
know and he's a billionaire he's a
billionaire I think that he could have
helped with their legal defense fund um
you know and he only just started
talking about them again now that he's
running but he ignored them for like I
mean two years yeah I mean it's really
unfortunate and I I think the those are
two main reasons but uh you're asking
kind of a timeline it had nothing to do
with my mom well yeah it was long before
then and it had nothing to do with I
mean I've been a DeSantis fan and
supporter you know because I saw what he
was doing in Florida I mean you know to
be clear I don't I'm not trying to say
like I know this is only for personal
reasons I was just curious what
separates
and I just want to say that I do uh at
the moment really heavily prefer Trump
but I'm sympathetic to all of those
criticisms fair and see this is this is
how it should we we should be able to we
should be able to talk and disagree but
you know still we're on the same side at
the end of the day don't be afraid I
think one of the one of the main reasons
that Trump is going up in the polls is
because of desantis's failures and less
because of Trump's successes disagree it
has to be because it's a there's only
100 that they can they can tell you
because Trump's not doing anything no he
is doing something he's turning his base
against DeSantis who I want to tell you
something a little story I used to run a
merch store before I started gays
against groomers it was called the base
Patriot I had merch on there that said
make America Florida it was my
best-selling t-shirt all of my followers
and supporters were Trump supporters
obviously you know like all of my every
single person that bought something from
that store was a trump supporter now
three days before the midterm election
Trump decided to have a little meltdown
and he went on an unhinged unprovoked
attack against DeSantis and hasn't
stopped attacking him since he has
started calling him to sanctimonious and
desanctus which is I don't know what
that means um but uh you know I believe
that the cult of personality is so
strong with Donald Trump that these lies
and names and and slander that he's
throwing at DeSantis is literally
changing the minds of these people who
once not very long ago loved DeSantis
and we're saying make America Florida
that makes no sense though how does that
not make sense how could someone be a
trump supporter to the degree that they
would vote for Ron DeSantis until Donald
Trump told them not to and then they
decided Well the polls were completely
reversed not long ago right so your
logic makes no sense yes it does because
someone someone was going to vote for
Trump
until Trump told them not to and said
okay I'll vote for Trump instead yeah
that makes no sense yes it does they
were either a trump supporter no it's
not that they're they weren't anti-trump
but they preferred DeSantis and all
these polls if you remember from a few
months ago like six months ago there
were a million polls all the time who do
you want to see the nominee Trump or
DeSantis and DeSantis was winning every
single one then Trump started going on
his unhinged attacks every single day
the people who didn't like Trump
believed Trump over to santus
yes but I'm not saying that's no failure
no no I'm not saying that they didn't
like Trump I'm saying that they saw that
that just DeSantis was a better option
and now between the the constant like
pressure campaign from Trump slandering
DeSantis and making everybody think he's
some Rhino you know you talk about AI
generated art I mean DeSantis posts I
mean Trump posts on Truth social Ron
DeSantis writing a rhino I mean you know
Photoshop I thought that one was more
obviously a joke
you're making a really good you're
giving me a really good example of
exactly what I've been talking about in
Rhonda Sanchez's failures it makes no
logical sense
I was for DeSantis last year I went on
the daily wire show and said he's got
more attacked he's got a better track
record yeah I think he's he's gonna he's
gonna be the guy that's also true and
then earlier in the year when I was like
50 50 because Trump had started the
campaign and started talking about what
he wanted to do he said schedule F I'm
like okay it could go either way Ron
DeSantis made some mistakes when I point
those out I get relentlessly attacked in
a way I've never been attacked before
the DeSantis campaign itself attacked me
and people started saying like why is
the disados campaign going after Tim
Poole like this I'm not saying it was
the craziest thing in the world it was
like a series of tweets over a few days
resulting in me getting bombarded by
people insulting me I I shrug it off and
I'm like wow in response to bad press
the Santa's campaign lied and then
instead of
letting it ignoring it they decide to go
on the offensive that was one example
that personally affected me and I was
like so that dropped me off from 50 50
to 55.45 then Ron DeSantis published
deep fakes his campaign to the Santa's
war room
and then when I said yo that's crossing
the line once again I started getting
intense heat from them telling me that
they're allowed to do it because Trump
once posted a picture of Iran writing a
rhinoceros that has nothing okay and you
and I spoke about this before I don't
understand how you know these things
that are put out by his campaign or by
the war room or by you know whatever
accounts and retweeted whatever the case
may be I don't understand how that can
change your support from the actual
candidate because like I can explain it
to you okay yeah for one Rhonda Santos
has surrounded himself by people who are
not competent and when faced with not
even criticism the the first thing the
DeSantis people start attacking me for
was that I was shocked to find out that
jazz Jennings got trans surgery in
Florida while he was governor and the
response from the campaign was to lie
claim it didn't happen and then tell me
that Ron didn't have a time machine
which was like the weirdest thing ever
because all Christina Pasha had to do
was Tech respond to my tooth a winking
Emoji saying Ron's on it and I would
have been like great instead it is
illegal now you know it wasn't it and
and still under DeSantis so these things
are going on I didn't say Ron failed I
was like is this going on in Iran and
they relentlessly attacked me for it the
response from the Trump Camp was to use
that against wrong now my my point about
Ron uh losing support and your argument
not making senses my my support for Ron
and my departure from him yeah has
nothing to do with Trump saying anything
I know it has such a deep fakes which is
what my point was and other things my
point was it doesn't it's not about
Trump's successes Trump doesn't have
very many rights no he doesn't it's
about Ron's failures his campaign and
his supporters inability to address the
mistakes he's making double down and
defend everything he does no matter what
like they're in a cult but get but again
what does that have to do with the
actual candidate and the way Rhonda
santis leads and has led in Florida
which turns Florida in literally the
French State it's literally bad
leadership um I could answer that I I
disagree he's got bad Personnel who are
doing bad things no you don't have to
explain I understand I just deserve
similar to how Donald Trump put fauci in
charge like if if uh fauci was in charge
and Trump should have Trump should have
taken control because he was in charge
as the president and he acted like he
wasn't kind of in a way which is very
strange he should have been making all
the calls not letting other people do it
um or signing off on other people's
decisions like that it was his job but
so if Ron DeSantis makes bad Personnel
decisions we could see another weird
doctor calling the shots maybe it
wouldn't be a doctor this time it could
be somebody though that's not a good
pick I mean well yeah you look at the
people that Ron has put in though like
in his administration you look at the uh
what is it called I'm gonna get I'm so
bad with like uh titles but the guy in
charge of the medical stuff down there
Joe latapo I think that's he's the
Surgeon General sorry thank you I swear
I'm actually this is the fascinating
thing let me let me read the Super Chat
from General kale says Tim blames the
Sanders for his bad team but defends
Trump by blaming it on a bad team I
quite literally never did that I said
Trump made a mistake and hired dumb ass
people and took bad advice from people
like Sheldon adelstein I can say it a
million and one times
and Rhonda Santa is currently on a
similar path and I don't like it and
Ronda Sanders won't own up to his
mistakes and I don't like it and Donald
Trump was never my first pick I didn't
vote for him in 2016 and I only liked
his foreign policy and him Banning
government contract with well companies
I will take Donald Trump right now
because he's more likely to fire people
than Ron is these are these are
basically but he's gonna hire Lindsay
the more the more the Santa's people lie
about what that position is the more I'm
just going to keep telling like pointing
out that the Santa supporters are just
lying about what's going on and refuse
to accept that Ron has screwed up if you
can't look I don't care if Ron wins or
loses I'll just tell you this right now
if Ron can't get a hold of this and his
supporters can't accept it he will lose
and he deserves to lose okay that's it
fair I just want to say that Trump will
drain the swamp with Lindsey Graham by
inside don't even know if he'll do that
but if it's 51 Toronto sentence is 49
I'll put my bet on the 51 percent and
that's been my position the whole time
I'm bullish on Vivek Rama Swami man you
seem you know he just seems like your
guy
I am literally not kidding
okay how is it that Charlie Kirk
Alex bruceowitz you're gonna say that
very like when there's come in here okay
Steve Bannon and I can tell them to
their faces Trump screwed up Trump
screwed up Trump I'm not talking about
them I'm talking about like the most
important
no I'm not talking about you know like
these big names like these famous
whatever people in the political world
I'm talking about your average supporter
um you know Trump says uh Ron DeSantis
is a meatball the next day all you see
in the replies of a DeSantis tweet is
meatball Ron meatball run Ron desantis's
Jeb 2.0 Trump says the next thing you
see is Jeb Jeb Jeb you know yeah like
you guys are fighting with each other no
no but it's just like everything Trump
parents or Trump says and it's instantly
true
for Where We Are
I did not vote for Trump in 2016. I
voted for Trump in 2020 on a few key
issues I am not very strongly
Conservative Republican and I'm not
super concerned about a lot of the
issues there's a handful of culture War
issues I like I think Rhonda Santos did
a very good job on a lot of them the
Trump supporters and the Santa
supporters are going at each other
relentlessly
I as someone who don't really care for
the most part say hey look at look at
bad thing I get attacked by De Santa
supporters I look at Trump and say hey
look at bad thing Trump supporters say
let me argue with you I don't get the
level of vitriol hate and zealotry
become support okay the second maybe you
do no the second I come out and say
anything negative about Trump I'm
instantly called a rhino I'm instantly
called a shill I'm instantly called
every name in the book we talk crap
about Trump all the time and we don't
get the level that we get from the Santa
supporters okay like we've had lucrative
you have a vastly different experience
than me and a lot of people that I know
so yeah I mean so so who's to say which
version is correct
the whole what do you mean Trump will
win because because his supporters are
crazy because if people are I mean that
could people like me the Libertarians
and this effective liberals who come on
this show if their experience of trump
supporters tends to be arguments and
their their experience of descent of
supporters tends to be vitriol they're
going to lean against Santas okay I just
want to be clear when I say A supporters
are crazy I'm talking you I don't want
you to think that I think I respect
Trump supporters I'm friends with Trump
supporters so many people in my
organization are Trump supporters when I
talk about like The Crazy Ones I'm
talking about like these you know
ideologues these Trump ideologues that
are enraptured by like the cult of
personality yes you know I I want to
make that very clear because I'm not I
don't like attacking people like that
and I'm not trying to paint a broad
brush doesn't you say that's also
something that happens in different
candidacies like there are people who
are absolutely Die Hard DeSantis fans
who are just gonna agree with whatever
he says and they're going to be
extremely angry with you if you
criticize them and there's something
I've noticed by the way right so I I
think with the way I've been careful
about my messaging uh I haven't really
said anything all that bombastic my main
points about like the Trump DeSantis
thing have basically been
I I think it's not great for the
Republican party that these two guys are
fighting in an Ideal World they would
get along with each other when I see you
know Trump dunk on DeSantis it doesn't
like Thrill Me The Way him dunking on
Jeb Bush did I don't go oh this is
awesome part of me goes it's sad because
I think DeSantis does have a lot to
offer this country but that said even
when I've said things like I think that
Trump has a far broader appeal with
respect to his charismatic Powers than
DeSantis and I don't think DeSantis gets
people as excited I've had people very
angry with me just for saying that which
I think is is a very mild criticism you
know regarding what you said earlier
that Trump supporters are crazy I think
maybe you spoke it was a little
heavy-handed what you said that it's
that I in my opinion that cultism is
makes is crazy people that are be fall
into cultism are falling into a crazy
methodology not that they themselves are
it's just that that is a crazy way to
behave to love someone no matter what is
a crazy way to behave well if you look
at like the signs like so there's this
graphic that was floating around like
the seven signs you're in a cult and
like all of them you know let me look
these up yeah yeah read it read them can
we read them because it's amazing and
you just see if it if it makes you think
of any and this is from the Atlantic I
don't know if I'm gonna there's a medium
has 10 signs there's a lot of different
signs apparently okay I don't know this
one let's see there's a couple opposing
critical thinking isolating members and
penalizing this isn't the one it's from
the Atlantic no just dishonoring the
family unit no it was basically just
about like the leader it was it was like
basically the leader can never say
anything wrong the leader like how to
Santa supporters
I mean
when
ever any point ever I have criticized
you know the ad the The Pride ad that
went out I don't think it was nearly as
bad as I do have a tweet if you want to
look it up like a week again I have no
sense of time but very recently when the
ad came out um that wasn't put out by
his campaign it should be noted
um but I was critical of it I was saying
do I love to see that as a you know as a
right-wing lesbian no do I think it is
anti-gay and homophobic also no but you
know I'm able to like I am able to see
faults and and maybe
um blind spots and and comment on that I
think I think this is the the seven
signs you're referring to okay let's
hear yeah I found leadership discourage
ignores or punishes questioning
leadership encourage self-policing
including confession and Punishment No
that's not it either I'll have to find
out the rest of them are all the same as
Atlantic no it was like in an image form
and it wasn't
cultism and politics interesting because
you you'd like to think you're voting
for ideas and behavior like policies but
you're really just voting for a human
that can turn on you at any moment yes
all right this is and that is a
massively important point I completely
agree with you we should be greatly
concerned with a person's policies but
one thing that has always driven me
crazy about the left is whenever one of
their leaders gets caught up in
something like a sex scandal and this
was huge with Clinton their response is
to say well we shouldn't care about the
moral quality of our candidates all we
should care about are the policies as if
they're not a human being they're just a
set of policy prescriptions no you need
a leader in that position so you want
someone who behaves morally and I think
it's perfectly legitimate to point out
the immoral behaviors of any candidate
in any party and I'm completely willing
to bite the bullet on that with Trump
but what really drives me crazy is when
I do point out just the human appeal the
fact that there's more Charisma with
Trump and people say well you know
policy matters more I can say in a sense
yes absolutely if it were up to me we
would just choose People based based on
policy but when you're picking a
candidate the thing you do have to
consider is are people going to want to
grab a beer with this guy because that's
going to determine I think how many
people vote I think that isn't up here
yeah it's just another one not
necessarily age but health of the brain
brain health like if these are these are
all reasons why last year I was saying
Rhonda Santos was the guy for the job
Trump's old Ron's younger yes exactly
Ron's got great policies no more
geriatrics he's uh uh he's he's got
youthful vigor and military service
things that Donald Trump doesn't have
and then when Donald Trump relaunched
his campaign and there were a few key
issues especially relating to the war in
Ukraine and I don't I I believe Trump
will end it over I don't think even
Trump as a person with words will end I
think the Trump Persona will be a
contributing factor in ending it which I
talked about earlier
uh put me at like I don't know we'll see
you know 50 50 I like Rhonda Sanders is
a great great proven track record in
Florida and then Ron made a bunch of
mistakes notably the big issue one of
the big issues for me was the Deep fake
thing yeah which his campaign has
completely refused to acknowledge
apologize for I just don't think it's
that big of a deal like I and you know I
think the media lying is the biggest is
one of my biggest pet peeves one of my
biggest issues I've complained but it's
not a lie it's not a lie the photo is
not real he never did I mean he he may
have hugged fauci but that picture was
not real but he did Embrace fauci huh
three of the it's three photos okay
whatever he he never hugged fauci uh
those photos are not real those three
photos whatever are not real but he did
Embrace fauci and that is worse he did
embrace fauci it's a lot worse than just
hugging him one time he embraced faucism
he let fauci run the freaking country
so I don't understand why that's such a
big deal but Trump embracing fauci is
not so uh but no no you can say that
both are bad and you can say that one of
the issues with the Santa making one of
the issues with DeSantis making these
deep fakes is that it's a great
deflection point for Trump if DeSantis
wants to bring up Trump's relationship
with fauci during the debates or any
other candidate that wants to bring that
up Trump just goes more lies more deep
fakes and he can say that credibly
because there was a deep faith
I think voters are smart enough to
understand that people are bringing up
you know how he handed the presidency
over to him and not just like a two
second clip from a a quick ad like but
the thing is like a quick sound bite
response is very persuasive to the
American public Trump just being able to
say you've made deep fakes of me and
fauci we're not going to listen to you
you have no credibility here and the
moderator is going to say this is
correct this Governor DeSantis you did
do this how do you respond and if I was
DeSantis I would say you literally
embraced fauci maybe you didn't hug him
like in this picture but you embraced
him not literally she's confessing like
you figuratively your presidency you
embrace and the country was destroyed
because of that decision by you the
danger is Trump's going to interrupt him
and say he's confessed he's admitted it
that's what I'm talking about every
weekend what about his and we'll see how
it plays out if Trump even goes why
isn't Trump going to the debate I'd love
to see it the danger I see with deep
fakes is that we're still early in the
technology so in four years you'll be
able to make a video of someone doing
whatever you want it will look exactly
real life and if you put real life Jamie
if I put that over the video of you
doing something that you didn't do even
if I think metaphorically it counts
that's dirty I think that it would be a
lot worse if it was Trump like sucking
some dude off right like that would
never be in a campaign ad but something
that like is very obviously you know in
real life never happens not yet maybe it
did but I'm just saying like him hugging
fauci in a picture uh a fake picture
when he actually like embraced him
figuratively and like for over a year
two years or something uh I I don't
think that that's comparable to like a
deep fake of me you know kissing a guy
proving that I'm straight you know like
trying to say see she's straight like
that's different I think but if it was
you doing something killing someone and
it looked real well yeah that's terrible
yeah but the technology the technology
is already there we already almost yeah
it's almost exactly real I don't think
that you can take it that extreme from
what from this to Santa said I just
don't it's just it's the beginning of a
long tunnel Adventure yeah it's a
crossing of the Rubicon in in we have we
have long talked about the dangers of AI
uh we've talked like you know a side
note Elon launch launches xai more is
coming we should talk about that media
is gonna start they've already announced
I think GMG Gizmodo media I think
because Moto Media Group is firing
journals they're gonna do AI content
instead but AI can only imitate it can't
create so what happens is instead of new
information getting generated it
regurgitates existing information feeds
it back into the ink it creates a
feedback loop so so what DeSantis did is
a component of that very very bad thing
should not have happened crosses the
Rubicon into very dangerous territories
where we're going to start seeing very
subtle manipulations in politics we can
tolerate none of it the only way we
navigate It Is by making it
unconscionable to do sure so Rhonda
Santos goes to zero so long as he's done
the unthinkable oh okay I still think
it's in my opinion not worth abandoning
your support of the potential you know I
mean the greatest politician I believe
in the in the Republican party right now
that is running for president that
shines against Trump in every way
um you know that's just my opinion and I
respect yours Tim and like I said we
should be able to have these
conversations okay like you know this
isn't Twitter we should be able to have
healthy debate
but like and still be on good terms like
I still respect you I respect your
opinion I think Rhonda Sanders is the is
the best politician in the country hands
down I want to have him in here
why wouldn't you want him to be
president over deep fake he's
incompetent and he's mad You Gotta Have
It All right there's a lot of arguments
against groomer stuff yeah dude that's
why I'm here what's it up to well what's
happening we we do we do have breaking
news we do have breaking news that we
have to jump to uh ladies and gentlemen
wow Ray apps to be criminally charged
for events on January 6th his attorney
says yeah this is a big one why did it
take this long because he's suing Fox
News I think he just announced that's
the next bit of news but the Revelation
was made in a lawsuit that Epps filed
against Fox News on Wednesday that
accused the network and former host
Tucker Carlson of defaming him so it is
because of this lawsuit that he is I'm
sorry it is because of the loss that we
know he's been criminally charged I
suppose the argument there may making is
that he's being charged because of them
or something I don't know dude here's
the thing let's say let's just say okay
wow we'll play Make Believe for a moment
we'll say you know what this is just
some guy who went there he wasn't
working with any kind of federal agency
uh and he hasn't been protected by his
status as someone who worked with them
even so even if we want to say that's
the case good this guy should be charged
you're Whispering you're instigating the
day before telling people that they have
to go into the capitol everyone starts
calling you a Fed you're still doing it
going around and instigating you're
whispering in the ear of the first
person to break a barrier down before
they break the barrier down why did it
take so long for this guy to be arrested
all right apps lawyer blamed Carlson for
the potential forthcoming charges take a
look at it
stop stop thank you Tucker Carlson
it wasn't like yeah yeah no it was
Tucker Carlson's fault Tucker Carlson
was actually whispering Ray Epps ear
before Ray Epps whispered in everyone
else's ear to start breaking the
barriers down you know what Tucker is
still going to destroy Fox News even not
being there because if this you didn't
know if he wins if if Epps you know has
a case here against them then uh
right now oh I'm OCD about typos no I
mean this is very real um I've spoken
about ray ops a bit in the past we've
had some conversations about him in
about January 6th and just how
interesting it is that he was so clearly
involved in instigating and yet he never
got in any trouble uh and so look him
being charged is a win-win regardless
when you look at how many people were
rotting away in prison in solitary
confinement we're having their rights
violated for doing things like entering
the building just a a fraction when you
look what happened to Brandon straka
yeah they they claimed he was he was
outside of the capital and they claim
that they heard him saying that people
should go in or something along those
lines and there's not even footage of
him saying it they just claim the voice
saying it on camera is him and then he
ended up having to plea down to avoid
prison time and this guy was was
whispering in people's ears telling them
to break barriers down was telling
people on January 5th that they needed
to go into the capital and here it is
July of 2023 and he's now being charged
this is ridiculous two and a half years
later two and a half years later and I
just love that he's saying Carlson is
he's blaming Carlson for the upcoming
charges I just tweeted uh thank you
Tucker Carlson scholarship so is that
why he's announcing that they're gonna
Sue Fox for Tucker's voice because he
didn't do anything wrong and then Tucker
Carlson just made him look bad for no
reasons uh yeah this is really funny
look at Rolling Stones said they said
the lawsuit alleges the network
particularly its former host Tucker
Carlson painted apps as an undercover
federal agent in order to push a
conspiracy that the FBI helped to
orchestrate the riot in the aftermath of
the events of January 6 FOX News
searched for a scapegoat to blame other
than Donald Trump or the Republican
Party eventually they turned on one of
their own telling a Fantastical story in
which rayaps who was a trump that
participated in the Pro of the protests
real fast
agent was responsible for the mob that
broke into the capital and interfered
the peaceful transition of power The
Conspiracy Theory blah blah blah fat fed
fed do they mention here that they that
he's being criminally charged uh
if they said in may they were notified
by the that was the other article it
said that in may they were notified
Rolling Stones said that no it was the
artist had it before okay yeah I don't I
don't know if uh
they conveniently left that yeah I don't
think Rolling Stones bringing up that
he's blaming Carlson for being
criminally charged
how does that work if you're criminally
charged with something and then you try
and Sue the person that that got the yo
look at this look at this I'm sorry but
look it says Epps has not been arrested
for his involvement and Carl's and
others have alleged the justice
department is protecting him because
working for the FBI yet in the lawsuit
Epps says he's being criminally charged
huh
recently informed apps had plans to
prosecute him yeah Rolling Stone fact
check your garbage unless the daily wire
is wrong I really doubt it well Rolling
Stone has they've really been bound 100
lately huh we saw their article about
that's bad about sound of Freedom did
you see their article wasn't there's
like a meme like a screenshot side by
side of the article about sound of
freedom and then their article about
cuties that Netflix yes that's right
they said it was like a great yeah I
gotta read this I gotta read this is
section 94 of the lawsuit finally in May
23 the Department of Justice notified
apps that it would seek to charge him
criminally for the events on January 6
2021 two and a half years later the
Relentless attacks by Fox and Mr Carlson
and the resulting political pressure
likely resulted in the criminal charges
wow Tucker Carlson can I buy you a beer
yeah you can actually
the question is when they publish these
kinds of stories trying to smear Tucker
and apps is the person we're supposed to
be sympathetic to who do they think is
going to buy that like who who in the
country is gonna go oh man because
everyone on the right is gonna say
either a this guy is a Fed uh or B he's
somebody who got away with it when he
shouldn't have when you look at people
riding in prison over far lesser
wrongdoing uh and what the left is going
to say is this guy's an insurrectionist
who do they think this is appealing to
who who's going to shed tears over this
guy yeah right like did Tucker Carlson
accused him of inciting violence at the
Capitol and now he's gonna get charged
for it and Rolling Stones defending him
that's amazing that's well that's why
you know something's up what is this
that's why you know something's up with
this guy why would one of the
insurrectionists be defended by Rolling
Stone by basically everyone in the media
everyone in media everyone has
acknowledged him fact Checkers have have
come to his defense and said he did
nothing wrong come on yeah they love
that guy he's on here saying stuff I
believe is that correct he's on video j6
is a domestic terrorist but they love
this guy the guy who is on camera on
January 5th saying we need to go inside
the capitol dude he says that true
crowded people and they start cheering
fed fed fed fed and yeah they start
chanting at and pointing at him so he
was inciting yes he was inciting and
then lo and behold the next day they all
do the thing he said that they should do
the night before right after he whispers
into somebody's ear and that person
breaks down one of the barriers and it
is July of 2023 and we're just getting
word that this guy might be charged and
it's because of Tucker Carlson are you
kidding me what's interesting are you
kidding is it they announced that they
were going to charge him in May but I
haven't heard out anything about it
until today which is two and a half
months later uh two months later I guess
Tucker is a National Treasure I I deeply
respect this man he stopped an
insurrectionist him he brought an
instructions to Justice he provided
evidence
about uh Jake chancelly I believe his
name right now Jacob Chancellor showing
him walking through the halls with a
police escort and them even trying to
open doors for him and he also exposed
right apps as one of people inciting the
violence and and the tearing down to the
barricades telling people to go inside
the thing about this whole January 6th
thing is you'll find most people even
Donald Trump himself says there were bad
people there they should be charged but
some of them many of them weren't I
think everybody agrees the violence the
fighting was bad even Trump posted on
January 6 our side believes in law
enforcement the media tried lying about
all of it trying to claim that he was
egging people on to go there for
violence Tucker Carlson exposes the lies
in the manipulations while also
criticizing someone who actually incited
violence that is the balanced honest and
moderate approach to what happened we
don't like the violence on January 6. we
don't like the innocent people being
charged Tucker is effectively calling it
out so effective it seems Epps is
actually finally getting charged for
being a principal actor and inciting the
violence that day it's just crazy
remember when when Trump said go over
there and March peacefully he was
actually sending out a top secret
right-wing doggle so I don't know if you
know this but every uh conservative in
the country every right winger actually
has a chip in our or brain and when
right-wing pundits say things that sound
totally innocuous they're actually
telling us to do something evil so Trump
activated that magic power and he said
go over there peacefully and have your
voice heard and of course what he was
really saying is you know like enter the
the building and commit acts of violence
uh now Ray apps on the other hand when
he was saying enter the capital what he
was actually dog whistling was be
peaceful no no have your voice heard
it's a song everyone's getting it back I
don't know Trump issue it's a song about
uh computer programming enter the
capital just meant like press shift and
it was misgender it says we gotta enter
the cat no you can understand it's a
song about computer programming it was
just like Rock the Casbah for computers
you know it's all big misunderstanding
and now he's going to jail he's going to
jail because the Tucker Carlson is fake
news I mean seriously these people hold
on a second does anyone in the media you
think that Tucker Carlson has any
influence over who's charged the only
reason he has any say on this or that
he's related to this is because he
showed actual footage of what the guy
was doing to the American people to the
point where the media couldn't ignore it
Tucker Carlson can't just fabricate
charges against the person and then have
that person go to jail what what world
are they living in what world do these
people live in where Tucker Carlson can
falsely accuse you of a crime and you go
to jail
a world where they falsely accuse people
of crimes they go to jail but they
should know that Tucker doesn't have
that ability wouldn't it be
great kind of power I want Tucker and
power I don't like you
like you have you sent to prison I'm
actually
team Tucker no all I can do is say
actually shame is the one who can
actually do his voice actually
it's about you on my telephone just
interviewed on Andrew Tate you guys see
it I did not it was okay I didn't watch
the whole thing you went to Romania is
that right yeah no I mean you have to I
guess I watched a decent amount of it
and I think it's really great for people
who aren't familiar with Andrew Tate but
for anybody who's watched or listen
Andrew Tate you're like like it's it's
his thing it's a Spiel it's the advice
Tucker didn't give too much of himself
in the interview it's mostly just tape I
only I've only seen Clips I only saw
like the first 10 minutes
um but you know regardless of the who it
is that he's interviewing I just love
how many views his videos you know these
these this show of his is getting on
Twitter because I mean every day more
and more you just continuous continue to
see that Legacy Media is irrelevant and
is dying and everybody should celebrate
that dude can we show us like him in a
leather jacket too can we talk Chillin
can we can we talk about it uh corporate
corporate media I know I love that new
picture you're taking a story out from
Daily Mail msnbc's Micah Brzezinski
blames 80 year old Biden's staff for
making him look old argues his aides
should be making sure he doesn't fall
over and should be controlling his
schedule oh my god dude these could you
who watches these people and thinks
they're like smart critical thinkers oh
my God no I think that's actually really
important they're hurting their own
argument like
the people who follow it are like tell
me they made it where to stand and how
high to jump they said it's a somewhat
Salient Point Mika's saying like you
know we've done stage performances you
don't necessarily know where all the
pitfalls are on the stage when you're
done you hopefully someone's gonna point
to the exit for you otherwise you're
looking around like where's the exit I
just got here and she's saying that the
handlers should like let them know ahead
of time you're going to be walking off
over here there should be people waving
him things like that but at the same
time she's also kind of admitting that
he's 80 and frail like mentally not
stable because like realistically you
look around really quick you're the
president you can do whatever you want
you can laugh and joke with people as
you're looking around you can make a
display of it but the guy's so old and
it looks like even like his musculature
is having a hard time holding his bones
up sometimes I like how P that's true
the the fact that you can blame this
man's staff for the fact that he looks
old is remarkable to me that's one I
didn't think I'd hear that you know the
speech impediment one was wild enough
when he said poor kids are just as
bright and talented as white kids or you
know when he said 200-shaba to pressure
or about a calf care
and they're like well that's just that's
like a speech impediment it's like what
kind of speech and kind of makes you say
that that's not a speech impediment it's
the dementia yeah or no it's it's called
um Biden nepheiji yeah exactly it's so
so weird some weird uh disease that's
unique to him yes let's jump to the
story from deadline I'll make sure we
get this one in uh uh before we go to
super chats ladies and gentlemen from
deadline Jim Caviezel Thriller sound of
Freedom knocks Insidious Red Door from
number one spot they can't just write it
can they
write the headline
sound of Freedom box office number one
just write that
they had to write in such a way that you
they don't they don't say it even in the
article they don't explicitly say it
they just say like it hit four million
dollars and then Red Door was 3.5 so
knocked down from just say sound of
freedom is number one ladies and
gentlemen with uh your viewing of the
film your support this film about child
trafficking is number one the reason why
I'm so excited for it parallel economy
obviously it's a good move you should
see it obviously child trafficking is
bad but there are a lot of movies about
a lot of issues that we watch okay this
is about indie films Shifting the
cultural narrative onto issues that we
need to talk about problems that need to
be stopped that for a long time they
claimed weren't really happening in the
weirdest of ways the Epstein stuff they
said oh that's nonsense and then he got
arrested for it and then Max Maxwell got
convicted for it and then prince Andrew
got ostracized and shunned for his
involvement and there's a lot of people
on that Client List we want to know
about now this movie comes out after
five years they try and shut it down and
this is what you can see a film about an
important issue number one it's a good
film it's got a 100 audience score in
Rotten Tomatoes even the critics like it
overwhelming it's like 80 percent that's
true critics enjoy it yup as much as
they want to rag on it and so it's a q
Anon film the majority of critics are
like school movie eighty percent
and now that's number one let's keep
supporting films like this so that we
can have alternatives to Hollywood and
the creepy grooming stuff that they try
and do in these films and the weird woke
ideology this is that path you know part
of what makes this movie so great I saw
it last night is Jim Caviezel is really
feeling this stuff I mean you can see it
in his eyes there's just it's enough of
his eye like you are with him you're in
his mind space and it is so powerful I
don't know what he went through to get
into this place where he's at right now
but God bless Jim Caviezel Batman yeah
he's a good actor I mean he was in the
passion right remember yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah he hasn't really done anything
major I feel like since then like he's
kind of he just comes back for well this
was well there's a reason so well
there's a famous story about how he was
a while ago yeah there's a famous story
about how he was cast in the passion Mel
Gibson called him and said hey do you
want to destroy your career awesome all
right let's do it did you see that the
passion oh yeah yeah we watched it
recently actually yeah we actually
rewatched it yeah I watched together
there's a lot I learned about uh in
terms of the politics of the era that I
didn't didn't know which I thought was
interesting uh in terms of this film it
was made five years ago so when you
mentioned like he hasn't been doing
stuff he actually was he was doing this
and then they blocked the film now let
me ask you guys why would Hollywood not
run a film like this I I can't imagine a
possible incentive they would have to
not want people to care about the issues
of child trafficking and other related
problems you know their response to it
just I mean they just tell on themselves
it's like why are you doing this at
least fake it you know like yep I don't
know they're kind of it puts them in a
catch-22 like they can't support it
because they don't want it exposed but
if they you know come out against it
like they have been it makes them look
suscious as there's that there's
that Viral uh there's that Viral tweet
where it's a guy who was like a writer
one of these digital Outlets was
claiming he tweeted something like the
only reason conservatives keep
complaining about kids being shown
graphic materials because they secretly
want to show kids graphic material
lights and then it was like it's one of
those like defiant L's or whatever where
it's like the next one is writer name
so-and-so gets arrested for questioning
images or something this is of course
this is all right this is it's one of
the only jokes the left has is you're
against this thing I bet you secretly
want to do that thing right that's why
this video was so good yeah thank you we
just released from yesterday but if you
like Believe In traditional marriage
like up you're secretly gay that's the
only explanation if you're like I want
uh literally with with every single
issue uh if if you're against grooming
oh well actually like you secretly want
a groom right um I'm not kidding I think
I've heard a version of this about
literally every topic it's true we get
that all the time on gays against
groomers yeah yeah you're like secret
groomers of course that's the only
reason that you'd oppose this I think
what's that line those protests too much
I think that's that's too much that
Shakespeare yes me thinks that's protect
that's too much and there is something
too
talking about how something is evil
maybe then they are the one that's
perpetrating it and they want everyone
to think they're not I understand that
methodology but that doesn't mean that
if you claim something is evil or wrong
that you secretly want to do it yeah
well lady doth protests too much me
thinks we live in this we live in a
culture where so many horrible
degenerate things have been normalized
so it makes sense that people would pay
attention to that and want to fix that
but whenever you do it's well that's
kind of interesting that you pay so much
attention that's like well one of the
number one culture War issues in the
country right now you think it's weird
about children being abused sexually and
otherwise like you freak yeah this line
is fantastic it's basically accusing
someone of virtue signaling uh it is
Queen Gertrude in response to insincere
overacting of a character uh to prove
his uncle's guilt blah blah the lady
doth protests too much me thinks I'm
just going to say that to people now who
are virtual signaling it's a great play
if you haven't seen Hamlet before see it
see a good version of it uh Billy
Madison you know
so they're watching actors in the play
do this like faux scene about the murder
of I think it's about the murder of
Hamlet's father uh and then the mother's
like I had something's off about this
and she doesn't know that her husband
murdered her her old husband so her new
husband I could explain this way better
I don't want to spoil it that's why I'm
kind of now you're stamping around but
yeah it's a four 500 year old play
um so Hamlet's mother's uh and his
father was killed in the beginning of
the play so then his uncle comes in and
marries his mother and turns out his
uncle killed his father
um but his mother doesn't know that and
she's looking at the play like
something's off about and they're trying
to it's a great absolutely phenomenal
story right we're gonna have to go check
I hope I got all that right I looked up
the I was in it I played Laertes the
current numbers for sound of freedom
from Box Office Mojo 49 million 497 837
so that's fantastic
it is Wednesday if every single person
watching this goes and sees it what is
that that's not gonna that's not enough
that's not enough we need everybody
every single person watching this to
bring their friends and family to go see
it so that this film can crack 100
million dollars let's do it look I'm I'm
willing to see it again uh I also think
that if you can it's good to contribute
to the free ticket
um funds that they have for people who
can't afford to go see the movie but
would like to have you heard about
there's a bunch of videos being shared
on social media of people being kicked
out of the theaters and getting refunded
no I haven't seen that yet because
there's too many people there no no no
no reason it was actually I think
Newsweek reported this let me see if I
can uh they just don't they're trying to
prevent people from no idea I was gonna
say Sheamus would you go together if you
wanna here you go yeah
manure is forced to evacuate movie
theater video shows so the report
actually brings up that there's several
different videos where people in various
theaters are told for some reason they
gotta Evacuate the theater and they're
given a refund and no explanation why
there's like Mr Christmas all over the
place trying to get people you know from
The Matrix trying to get people to not
see it they're just like oh no there's a
fire you have to leave a horrifically
horrifically awesome movie man I oh geez
it's a tough watch right I mean it is
there are parts that are very uh painful
and I I'm not sure how much I can say
without spoiling it but it
it almost um what's good about it is
at the end you do feel motivated to want
to do something because I don't think
like just given the nature of the
problem it's not a story that they can
just tie in any little bow like you get
that with Hollywood films a lot the
problem solved everything's fine and it
gives the audience a sense of
satisfaction it's a movie that you watch
and it's impactful and it's more than a
worthwhile watch but you walk out of the
theater feeling like there's so much
that needs to be done yeah it doesn't
just it's spoon feed you a victory like
so many films do like an archeology dig
where you find some of the artifact but
you haven't you've just seen the tip
exactly exactly you see a little bit of
it and and there are like there are
incredible true stories that are told
through that film about people who were
rescued and obviously seeing anyone
rescued is a wonderful thing to see but
the film doesn't shy away from letting
you know that the problems far from
solved right like the day has has not
been totally saved there's there are
there's work you have to do there's more
children being trafficked today than
when slavery was legal there's more
slaves there's more slaves in the world
overall yep something what 80 million
slaves in the world I think I think it
is true that there are more child sex
slaves today than there than there were
slaves back when slavery was legal oh
sorry it looks about like 50 million
slaves in the world so I was today but
yeah 50 million people in the world
living in slavery as of 2022. how do you
even begin to tackle that I mean I guess
you do what they did and what Tim Fowler
did well in the movie they bring this up
like a lot of this stuff is happening
outside the US we have no control like
it's just not here you know so that's
what Tim Ballard does he goes and he uh
yeah that guy is unreal I mean I think I
think he's here tomorrow actually oh my
God that's fantastic I Wish I Was Here
let me double shake his hand honestly
say hello bless him
normally we don't but now it's guests in
advance
of Hope
you feel sorrow you feel hope the film
it takes you on a roller coaster but the
film it's not just like it's this
emotional experience that you'll get
from film sometimes where it's totally
aimless and they're just manipulating
you it's giving you a real story
it's giving you Solutions
my goodness with uh Eduardo Vera uh he's
the director of the film correct wow
very excited for that very excited that
is huge gonna be great maybe I'll push
my flight back just I just want to shake
it I know I want to shake a sand too I
just want to say thank God bless his
wife too I hope I understand with him I
don't know if she's going to take the
trip
his wife is an incredible woman I I was
reading some of the differences between
the film and his real story and I'll let
him share on air what he he wants to
share what he's here because it'll be
more impactful for him but some of what
he said his wife said was like uh in
just her involvement and support is
incredible like what a sacrifice for a
wife to make yeah but oh geez well we'll
go into it tomorrow this dude's like I
know we got a bunch of kids but I'm
Gonna Save a whole bunch of other
people's kids and she's like okay yeah
do it it's crazy it's it's it's
incredible that was when I first cried
is when I I don't wanna I don't think
it's spoiling it but yeah it's too soon
you gotta let him see it you gotta let
him see it you people Everyone really
goes I haven't seen it yet you you want
you want to be a part of like this is
not a film you want to watch on
streaming in a couple months it really
is not like you want to see this in the
theater with fellow audience members
that's a good question it's more
impactful really you will find things
about that yeah because it was it was
pushed pushed around and rebuffed for
five years like it's actually shocking
that it's not just an in you know they
have like Indie theaters cities like
it's weird to me that yeah I don't know
thank goodness weird well it's great but
how did that happen uh a lot of a lot of
hard work there in Providence uh and
I'll also mention this like just to
reaffirm what I'm saying here and help
hit this point home like you don't want
to be watching this at your house
checking your phone there's distractions
everywhere like go see this film in
theaters support it as much as you
possibly can well it's still out I I
mean I really really really want to
recommend it I'd like to see this yeah
we got to call it the sound of Freedom
effect when there you go like we can
prove that the issues we care about we
will stop spending money on garbage and
we will start spending money on good
stuff we'll download apps like Public
Square and we're going to tell the Old
Guard and the Machine we don't need them
anymore so a film like this succeeding
does two things it makes child
trafficking the Forefront of major
issues that we need to address and we
should which of course the establishment
for some reason is very worried about
yep and it supports independent Studios
who are getting major films in theaters
but I just want to say it outright the
first 10 minutes of this movie man don't
give anything yeah it's the whole film
is is brutal but incredibly captivating
and I'll say this for every dollar that
you didn't spend on Bud Light you should
contribute that to the Pay It Forward
fund for this film think about it how
long is how long have you been
boycotting Bud Light how long have you
refused to drink it for how much do you
usually spend on Bud Light in that time
period if you can afford to I would take
all of that money and drop on the sound
of Freedom hey man
that's what you should do go watch the
sound of free Pay It Forward there's a
Pay It Forward option you can't see it
use it literally recommend it recommend
it to people bring yourself because at
the end they'll show you a church group
together to go see it they'll pop up a
barcode at the end of the movie after
the credits uh where you can scan it
with your cell phone to pay it forward
for someone else or to find free tickets
if there you know someone that can't
afford it they tell you to do it yeah
yeah that's weird but Paul your phone
right now if you have like an adults
group or young adults group or something
at your church I'm sure most I'm sure a
lot of Traders are already doing this
but this is something that that you
should plan y'all should support usually
support this film my attempt to go up
and goosebumps when I think about the
like little little kids like young kids
like dude
I know wow
well let's go to super chats if you
haven't already kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member of redtimcast.com by clicking
join us we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you
tonight and it will be a lot of good fun
we'll talk about some uh some uh you
know spicy issues before we get into
that can I just talk for very briefly
about gays against groups yeah I just
want to say uh yeah if you guys want to
learn more we are also in the business
of saving kids from the radical alphabet
ideology that is destroying the youth
right now
um that is telling them that they are
sexual beings and that they are born in
the wrong body and uh the work we're
doing is really important all of us are
from you know we're all LGB or t
primarily um gays and lesbians uh and if
you want to learn more help us out in
our fight just go to gays against
rumors.com and I'd I'd be remiss if I
didn't squeeze that in there that's why
I'm here first time I've ever heard
someone say that they're attempting to
make children's sexual they are they're
trying to sexually liberate children and
give them bodily autonomy I mean if a
child if a child can consent to
sterilizing themselves uh or chopping
body parts off what can I what what
can't they consent to it's like the most
extreme thing ever
um you know and the line from A to B
There is very very short all right let's
grab some super chats I'm not your buddy
guy says it's interesting the latest
season of Jack Ryan has U.S Intel
agencies being revealed to have be have
been weaponized by Far East powers to do
their bidding hmm oh really
never seen not far left Powers sure
Jay Marie says Ian I love your spirit
bro I have a special way of explaining
philosophy religion politics et cetera
in a matter that's very digestible I
think you would enjoy please swing by j
marie a thesis podcast nice Ian
literally does have the best Spirit
energy it's a conglomeration I want to
feel it from here like for real
excellent I love it Mike Kelvin says I
finally received my order from you guys
but strangely it only contains a bunch
of spoons and potatoes and I'm talking a
lot of spoons man
wow so look at that Tim blames me for
taking his spoons and they show up in
somebody's orders
do a video with Sheamus as The Spoon Man
it worked why why are you putting this
on me
it actually works out really well
because I have to make the joke that
crazy people accuse me of stealing their
spoons and putting them on the moon
insane people people can have arguments
and like people don't like me the worst
that's ever happened in that regard it's
like I'm walking down the street in New
York and someone's like if you're Tim
pool and I'm like oh hey but where's me
you're like crazy people who are like
ranting and scratching the walls and
they're like he stole my spoons man and
he put him on the moon yeah so so part
of why Tim I get it it's it was a test
Tim said before you host Tim cast for a
week you have to know what it's like to
have a lunatic accuse you of stealing
their spoons but in all in all honesty
you were taking his spoons downstairs
and keeping them
no it's a ridiculous accusation there's
no no this isn't it where are you coming
up with it's just it's just uh this
conjecture you're acknowledging this is
conjecture yeah that's all I needed to
hear thank you that's all the audience I
need to tell everybody the real story no
it's all it's nonsense the real story
like nonsense Allison is doing the
dishes and she's like uh Juno spoons
went I was like oh Sheamus might have
him hey Sheamus you have some spoons he
was like oh yeah and he walked up and he
put the spoons in the sink and then
Sheamus goes there's an Irish man living
under my house who steals my spoons how
many spoons was it like there was it's
not the whole story is made up so I have
no idea how many spoons there were look
I'm not the kind of person who would do
that I'm not thinking you know me you
know me I wouldn't do that I'm not the
kind of person who would do that
let's read more Super chats Heron gaming
news says my girlfriend and I watched
the sound of Freedom my girlfriend
couldn't stomach it because of her
history of being abused as a child well
unlike what the left always says about
lgbtq representation in movies this one
will help save lives and innocence I
wonder if she finished the movie I hope
she finished the movie I understand that
well in I said this uh I think yesterday
or the day before while I was talking
about this but it's very possible that
this is going to be a film some people
can't get through absolutely however if
you go to see it and you have to get up
and walk out of the theater there's a
conversation I was having with my
parents my mom said I want to see it but
I'm worried that you know it's going to
be too hard for me to watch and what I
said is
go see it and if you really need to get
up and leave the theater because it's
it's too hardcore for you it's too
difficult to watch which very well might
be you will know that your money funded
a good cause and helped spread awareness
and it's not wasted because it's not
like you're going to see a movie and
that it isn't good so you walk out of it
and the money is you know poorly spent
like this is an important movie that's
raising awareness even if you can't sit
through the whole thing uh it's it's
worth buying a ticket and going to see
it all right monk in training says Tim
working all the time the way you are is
unhealthy and your Grandpa died because
he worked himself to death it's a
marathon Marathon not a race I don't
think my grandpa worked himself to death
yeah that was like really personal
really fast about something they
couldn't possibly know yeah like yeah
I'm pretty sure you're completely wrong
my grandpa fell off a telephone pole
smashed his vertebrae and I had to spend
the last 20 years of his life in a bed
that's how I knew him serious yeah I uh
shout out to blame one of one of my
grandparents fathers is still alive the
other uh got sick and got sick of a sad
story but yeah I'm sorry here I don't he
didn't work himself to death in fact I
think the work was good for him maybe
there's like a shot I don't completely
disagree however uh I do work quite a
whole bit uh however I have no choice
but to take a week off so I kind of like
well I guess you know I'm not gonna cry
about it I want to do these things
happen I want to do movies with you as
you as the actor oh I don't want to do
that yeah yeah I do it bro like any good
you'd be great you're great at that
anyway but it would be I don't know it's
just a change of direction for a little
while like a good feature we're gonna
keep doing this oh next week I'm going
to a doctor who's going to be like
injecting my leg with things and like
the camera and they got to fix cartilage
and stuff we'll do uh if you guys
starring in a movie put one on each
house forever that's hilarious but like
a day we'll shoot during the day we'll
do IRL and uh evil wait what are you
talking about
did you did you not mute my I didn't say
anything all right let's uh here we go
here we go I wouldn't do something like
that just leave me alone says they've
extended side of Freedom sound of
freedom for another week in our theater
we're going to see it for the second
time Saturday bought t-shirts too that's
fantastic nice we just want you know
when the daily wire started making
movies I was like everybody should watch
these movies yeah we need to encourage
Studios outside of the creepy woke
Hollywood garbage exactly I totally
agree I just my one hope for the daily
wires that they don't start like putting
nulls in their films because Michael
Knowles yeah he's an actor of sorts
yeah yeah I just yeah that would be
originality if Michael Knowles started
starring an awesome hit movies to be
honest I'm a hypocrite because I've used
them in cartoons and he's done wonderful
voice acting for me oh yeah I would I
would like to see even daily wear by
sound of Freedom once it's cycling out
of the theaters and put it on the daily
wire people will subscribe we got uh
dreadnoughts upset he says Trump running
from the basement are you serious the
man Phil Stadium's doing rallies
DeSantis is a neocon shell Trump hasn't
filled a stadium uh since 2020. well and
my point was not engaging in debate so
Tucker is doing this forum and Trump's
not going to do it and Trump doesn't
want to debate that's specifically what
I was referring to Trump being like I
don't need to I'm not gonna yeah you
know I think he shouldn't I think I
think he's not just that one but the one
in August as well uh you know it's
actually in Milwaukee where I live I
really want to go if there's somebody
from Fox watching
um I know I maybe talked a little poorly
about your network a few minutes ago
I want to go to the debate cool someone
make it happen d-stock says I really
want a trump Lake ticket Carrie Lake
would be an amazing VP I uh I agree I do
think there are probably she's a top
contender in my mind but I do think
there may be better picks it's hard to
figure out who it would be however I
think Carrie lake is infinitely better
in Arizona and I think she'd be great
winning the senate seat I and I think
I'm pretty sure that's what her plan is
I'm just thinking about Carrie Lake
should be
it serving Arizona and then once she's
done all she can for Arizona then she
she upgrades to the federal so would it
be safe to say that the only Republican
vice presidential candidate that works
is Vivek Rama Swami no who else could be
in the Republican party yeah it's tough
I think like Byron I mean Byron is a
trump supporter he's endorsed Trump I
think Thomas Massey I think there's a
lot of great guys Rand Paul Massey
endures to Santa's yeah I know I'm
talking if DeSantis is if Trump is the
nominee Trump no if Trump is the Nami
I'd like to see like a Byron Donald's
I'd like to see you know somebody that's
uh maybe not Lindsey Graham I don't know
they're awfully close right now but I
don't know who Trump could pick because
for the longest time the only thing
anyone was saying was Trump DeSantis
that's not happen I think he likes dude
Byron Donald's awesome he's great
Byron's a good guy and I think you know
I mean demographically I think it could
help Trump has spoken I don't think
Trump will be the nominee he's spoken
very favorably Trump has of Vivek
ramaswamy there's at least a video I saw
was like have you heard of him his
name's Vivek Rama Swami
I'm not your buddy guy says RFK is not
the way he is crazy on the green stuff
he is yeah he's a Democrat I don't know
I mean yeah what do you expect he's a
Democrat you know because he's okay on
one issue and is exposing some stuff
that you know are bringing things to the
conversation
um but he should be the Presidential
nominee for Democrats I mean the
Democrats that'd be great absolutely
yeah I mean anybody but this Biden guy
well let's not say that because I don't
know be careful what you wish no no no
no no I wouldn't want to see like well
aoc's still too young but you know what
I mean here's a good one Tinky Winky
says first time Super Chat because
Serge's comments about John Deere last
night triggered me would you say I
wonder if he knows why they paint them
green so they can hide in the grass
while the real tractors do the work Red
Power baby that's a good one so like do
farm members have farmer jokes where
they're like they're hanging at the
farmer's bar or whatever and it's like
why are John Deere tractors green so
they can hide in the grass as the red
ones do the real work is that like it's
hilarious I don't know and all the
farmers laugh there is farmer was it
farmersonly.com or something yeah
farmersonly.com that exists now I want
to look into like farmer culture like
off the farm yeah well you know if like
you're you're looking for a significant
other they got to be able to raise
chickens that's yeah how are you gonna
survive in Apocalypse you know so but
then but imagine all of the the low
quality non-farmers flooding Farmers
Only and trying to find farmer mates I
almost clicked on it yeah I'm one of
those weirdos it's like well I live in
the city but I'm looking to be a farmer
own now you're not a farmer it's Farmers
Only is that discrimination the site for
country folks discriminating against
someone for their for their uh career
choice I think that's what every job
application does
that's true that has to be allowed right
let's grab some super chats
what do we have Diane Reynolds says no
candidate is perfect you need Friends in
Low Places sometimes it only matters if
they impact his decisions and for that
we should judge
I mean yeah that has happened you know
he said that uh didn't he say that Chris
Christie recommended Rey
um Trump did I mean Skylar Pearson says
Vivek is threatening to go Elon on the
federal bureaucracy at least a 75
percent head count reduction in the
first term also wants to staff with
Libertarians and knows the precise laws
that Empower him to do it I like this
Vivid guy yep he seems like a good dude
we will grab some more Adolfo says Vivek
also stated he would fire everyone I
could imagine him as VP
I mean that's a powerful ticket but I
just don't know if Vivek has the
there's like a there's like a like a
Persona there's like a character there's
like a demeanor there's like
it's not just about policy it's not the
only thing that matters what matters is
leader leadership isn't always just
about having the idea and the example I
often give is when I was on Occupy Wall
Street and this guy gets up on the
planner and he goes um should should we
March everybody and everyone just shrugs
and looks around and then some woman
goes my Jack and they'll scream let's
and then everyone screams and starts
marching that's leadership the idea
wasn't good the ability to rally and
convince people was what was what was
needed important so Vivek has something
powerful within them but he seems more
like a Cabinet member
like he would be a Cabinet member or
something not a VP
the status could be a VP
Trump could definitely not be a VP he
does not have the the character or
demeanor
you know let's grab some super chats
moose James says long time listener
first time superchat just got out of the
theater with my dad sound of Freedom was
an amazing movie depressing and
gut-wrenching but the best movie made in
the last 10 years oh yeah really good
really good yup
we will grab some more
what do we have what do we have
hunter killer says breaking news tornado
hits Chicago suburbs from Elgin to
Rosemont damage control underway whoa
you wanna look that up that's crazy
Chicago doesn't really get tornadoes too
often
yeah we had like a couple like alerts
when we were kids you grew up in Chicago
just outside the city yes where an area
don't talk to me sorry
good call yeah yeah we'll have to talk
actually well Tim and I originally like
when I was really little we lived in the
same neighborhood and then seriously
until we met yeah same neighborhood as
Jimmy door too yeah yeah that's right
it's not wild we'll have to talk
actually because I was born in Chicago
and um have family that lives in a
suburbs that's why I'm interested we'll
talk I don't think Sheamus was alive
when Jimmy was there though no there's
no way because I think I was like six
years old when Jimmy left yeah but it
was really cool when I met uh Jimmy Dore
the first time he's like so where are
you from and I'm like Chicago no kidding
me too where at and I was like Midway
area and goes no kidding me too where at
and I was like by mid like Midway area
South Side by Vietnam Park and it was no
kidding me too and then I was like I
lived on this street because I lived on
this street and it was like a block away
that's crazy that like Tim has such
little loyalty he would accuse someone
from the same neighborhood as as him of
stealing it's
outlandish I did thank you Ian
Sheamus you're evil
are you 13 evil you guys know I'm not
evil I'm not I believe you Sheamus
thinks that he can steal spoons and go
to confession it doesn't matter you guys
don't know true well here's the thing if
I actually did steal spoons I'd have to
have a firm resolution to never do it
again and I yeah in order to
confesses like this is a completely
theoretical I've never done something
like this it's a ridiculous before says
I have to agree with Sheamus's version
of the spoon event thank you it's common
knowledge that the Irish have not
evolved to the point of using hand tools
that's true team Luke thank you wait why
was he I'm Irish too me too why is that
team Luke I don't is is everybody in
here who's not Irish who doesn't have
Irish or just not Irish yeah I'm Irish
I'm Scottish accidentally offensive to
all of us how could you that that really
I thought it cleared me from the island
I didn't steal and you guys know me you
guys know the kind of person I am I
wouldn't do that are you Irish too Jamie
no I'm Jewish
um but can't Jewish people be Irish no
maybe
no I'm 98
uh Ashkenazi Jew let's see it in the
comments
that's the other two percent I don't
know I forget here we go Clifton stock
says Tim I just left the theater and
you've been lying to all of us oh that's
right sound of freedom is better than
you've been saying go see this movie
everyone and Pay It Forward God's
children are not for sale I said it was
a 10 out of 10. I don't know how it
could be better than that so you should
have said it was at least a 12 out of
10. no to be fair I did say it's like
it's not you know an absolute perfect
film nothing is but it gets very close
in terms of like
there are a lot of movies I've watched
from where I usually watch a movie every
night after the show I'm going to bed
I'll turn a movie on I can't remember
half of the movies that I watched
they're just like whatever yeah because
they're boring it's like you know I fall
asleep half the time but uh sound of
freedom is something I'm like not gonna
forget it's a good movie yeah
yeah man
all right the ferris was great too right
they've been knocking I know it's not
the same Studio well nefarious remember
we just watched that recently that was
so really good really good oh I really
want to see that you should yeah yeah we
really want to see that Matt Kelly says
I think this stream is being suppressed
I didn't see this video on my feed like
I do every day no notification nor do I
see it in the live tab is it because of
this the thumbnail oh actually yeah that
could be do you seriously think so
absolutely I was thinking about it I
think that's
itamus was like don't show that book no
yeah definitely those two words are
probably flags for YouTube that knock
down viewership that's crazy yeah but
you know it's your fault I guess so but
uh it'll have no impact on but kids can
read it yeah I hate that the truth this
is a children you can show it in schools
Amazon literally will not look it says
it's 18 plus but then here's the issue
this show can't just survive off the
idea that YouTube will share it with
people clearly this person who's posting
the Super Chat sought out the stream by
any means has it like like to watch it
right that's what we need if if people
don't want to watch the show on its
merits then we don't deserve to have
people watch the show like they
shouldn't watch it true so that's why
I've always been like look YouTube
censors us sometimes yeah well it is
what it is it's good when they give us
the bump because people discover it but
really it's about Word of Mouth for
everybody who's like I'm gonna tell
people about sound of Freedom you all
should be telling people about Viva and
Barnes and stick sex and Hammer and and
Tim castiral and insert other show
that's weird you didn't mention there's
one show you didn't mention which is
like kind of crazy which one you would
mention there's these there's just Ian
crossman.net yeah okay thanks for
bringing that up also like yeah you
acrosslin.net yeah and then if and then
once you're exhausted and you're tired
and you have nothing else and you want
to just get a chuckle you know there's
Freedom Tunes there's freedoms that's
right there is freedom I'm more
interested in shamer oh based yeah
rumble.com shamer that's my podcast
thank you Ian oh yeah
let's grab some more Super chats
what do we have here Matt Buller says
Tim is beyond illogical by saying it's
weird that people who have issues voiced
upon them go all in with learning about
norms and standards especially coming
from someone who dropped out of school I
don't quite understand what your point
is
I'm not sure how that applies to what I
was you say that one more time because I
think it was it's weird that people who
have issues foist upon them go all in
with learning about norms and standards
I don't understand what he's trying to
say
like I don't I I understand you're
making a reference to the argument I
made about people who are adamant about
issues that have been thrust upon them
that they've never experienced before
okay but I don't know what that has to
do with me not going to high school
you didn't go to high school no really
yeah wow what did you do instead uh I
was on the internet all day made
websites programmed video games played
music skateboarded I didn't know that
about you things that were substantially
more productive than sitting around in a
school wasting your time man talk about
it that's crazy I didn't know that yeah
I would do uh I did Flash animation
flash four
media flash I uh started teaching myself
to animate on flash three wow yeah yeah
that now that was even then it was very
out of date it was like 10 years old at
the time how old were you when you
started animating I was 12 when I
started teaching myself I used a
Shockwave to make a skate video Once
because I don't know I was doing you
know and then um I think before Premiere
was purchased by Adobe what was it oh
that's a good question yeah uh flash was
macro media right macromedia Flash and
then Adobe bought it what was I can't
remember what was premiere on making
skate videos we had digital cameras
where we could only take pictures and
then we got a mini mini uh what is it a
mini DV no no high eight was the first
camera we got
and then we got like this garbage little
lens because you needed a wide-angle
lens to home skate videos so I was
basically like learning how to do work
in the real world and all of my friends
were learning what like interrogative
sentences were for the 15th year in a
row no joke I'm like what are you guys
learning nothing
yeah it was crazy I had a friend who was
going to school for music business
and I was like you're in your third year
of college she's like yeah and I'm like
you're you're majoring in music business
yeah how many how many shows have you
put on how many bands have you managed
how many demos have you put together and
she's like none and I'm like isn't it
weird that I've managed more shows for
bands than you and you're in college for
this yeah it is a weird thing so I went
to I ended up going to school for
animation and there was a class where we
were you know everyone sort of had to
produce a short film and there were kids
who had literally never made an animated
short film before it's like what you're
in college for animation you've never
like just made an animated short by
yourself ever it's crazy it's crazy that
some of things like this is the thing I
want to do and then they don't like
dedicate themselves to it and try to get
as good at it as possible it's a bad
yeah oh it's a mistake to think that
school is going to make you what you
what you want to be you got to make
yourself what you want to be school is
an opportunity to do it you can go there
and then make yourself but you got to do
it exactly exactly
Tyler Brighton says as an anarchist
libertarian I will be voting Trump
that one's funny beast but I can
understand that because even when we've
talked to people like Dave Smith he's
been like yeah the foreign policy might
be something we just want to get it's
like we don't like all of it we think a
lot of it's bad we think a lot of what
like most of what he's doing is bad
but it's like if you can inch forward on
a couple good things do you just take it
my bigger issue is where's the
libertarian party candidates what's
going on yeah is there one I mean there
is there even did they announce one yeah
well they wouldn't announce like right
the Democratic party hasn't had a
primary yet Republicans haven't but what
about their primaries it feels like it
isn't as early as it is it's like right
we're still just out the gate
a green Clover says on deployment so
can't watch the sound of Freedom give my
Super Chat to the fund solid maybe we
can set up a fund to pay it forward fund
for sound of freedom
we should we should figure some out get
some people to the movie
Guardsmen norheim of the tanith first
says Tim's going to come back from
surgery to converted devout Catholic
audience amen
Jamie's gonna be like now that Tim's not
here and then he'll come back they'll be
like talk about some more episode is
going to be with like a different
theological expert yeah Tabernacle the
guests are already booked uh the
unfortunate thing is I guess you know
we've got we've got to inform the guest
like I'm not gonna be here uh you can
have to talk to me if they're gonna be
like yeah I think I can well can we get
a rain check nothing I can do about it
man like quite literally it's like if if
I don't go now what ends up happening is
then next week it's a day after a
consultation then next week it's like
two days off for scans or it's like I
can go to a specialist and they're like
we can get it all done in one week yeah
it's better it's better it's better to
just get it over with super brutal I
have to like sleep in the hospital
document it no I don't know about that
that'd be pretty cool I'm trying to
convince Luke to come out no ew why
would you do that here to come hang out
when you know we're out there that's
even worse you want to subject yourself
to him I thought you were punishing your
audience not you you need to heal Luke's
looking good on social media why would
you say that working out why would you
say that that's ridiculous for days
that's a ridiculous thing to say we are
changed that's there's no basis for that
there's no basis that is that's been
widely refuted by every expert on the
subject all right salty says DeSantis
initial reaction to covid was the same
as the left he only backed off his covet
policy because of his very conservative
State Assembly they pushed the agenda in
Florida he has he has just follows
what does that look like with a divided
Congress
I mean I think Ryan gets a lot of credit
for what the Florida Republican
legislature does too so we should give
them credit as well they're the ones
that are actually sending the bills to
his desk
let's grab some more Super chats what do
we got here Andrew wagaman says the use
of deep fakes is a lack of Integrity if
he would own up to it and condemn it
that would show that he has more honesty
and that's kind of the issue because
like I don't really expect a lot out of
trump in terms of like integrity and
stuff I can certainly say I think he
might fire people because he's angry at
them and wants revenge but the point of
Ron is that he's supposed to be better
instead it's like what I see the Deep
back thing is him doing what the
corporate press has been doing for years
in order to win their their so they want
Biden to win they want Hillary to win
they just make things up
Donald Trump posts annoying memes to a
lot of people some people think those
memes are funny Donald Trump insults
people a lot of people don't like that a
lot of people think it's funny there are
certainly problems with Trump supporters
as well but I don't like the idea of
producing deep fakes with the direct
intention of manipulating the public
with things that never happened
but they did figuratively
yeah so to make a video that says real
life Trump and intersperse manufactured
images with real images in order to
trick I'm just messing with you now no
but it is funny that it's like
Ron DeSantis is hoping to trick Trump
supporters or conservatives into voting
for him by making fake images about what
he doesn't need to trick him that's the
thing that's exactly like he could have
just been like
he didn't even need that one second I
don't even know why he did it but guys
you do understand that Ron DeSantis
himself did not make the ad like you you
talk about Ron DeSantis you can talk
about the campaign maybe but like saying
Ron your your aunt Iran DeSantis the
person the politician the candidate
because of something that you know is a
bad team
okay I mean but still like I just I was
really just poking fun again but that's
you know I mean that's kind of the issue
it's like Ron should have just come out
right away he got fact checked for it he
got slammed across the board for it
should have been like hey look it wasn't
me he did how do you know they that that
no but do you know every single person
employed by the campaign I don't know
maybe should have publicly announced it
was a mistake and that he was firing the
person responsible instead he's just
like shh don't tell anyone let's just
let it go away it's like smarmy PR stuff
what a fan I think it's I think that I
think it's a problem
all right we will grab some more super
jets
let's see what we got here
Marty McFly says is Jamie's point that
DeSantis deep fake photo is akin to a
political cartoon come to life why can't
a political political cartoon and now
have realism love the show
one of the arguments that was put
forward by Santa's reporters was that
Trump had Republicans had made a deep
fake of a future under Joe Biden and it
was a bunch of Deepak images of like the
apocalypse having happened and it's just
like okay and then The Descent
supporters brought up the the Photoshop
of Ron writing a rhinoceros which is
very obviously not real it's like
there's a big difference between a
hypothetical artistic future a meme and
an image that says real life Trump on it
to take pictures to be fair the image
didn't even look real it was like
clearly artistic like an artistic
rendition of the three images they
posted alongside the three real images I
only know the the I I haven't seen the
ad in how long ago was that again end of
June or beginning of June I think no it
was before then six months ago June 5th
yeah something about three five weeks
ago I think I'd have to watch it again
the only one that is sticking out in my
mind is that I know that really ruffled
feathers was you know him hugging fouchy
there's three fake photos of him hugging
okay so they're all hugging fouchy right
and there's three real photos of him
like standing next to fauci okay and
then they wrote real life Trump over it
okay yeah that's like no but I already
forgot my point that I was trying to
make sorry it looks like it was in
response to the June 2nd image of Ron
riding a rhino which you should see yeah
but it's just like smiling I don't know
but what's the difference okay so they
were artistic Renditions like they
looked like they were they were real
life Trump over it I put it next to real
things it looked like they were AI
generated like they did not even look
they didn't they looked real if you
didn't exactly yeah no I I the one
that's like you could bring it back up
but like the one that I have in my head
that I can remember clearly looks like
almost like a painting like it's not it
doesn't look like a photo like if I
would just snap a picture right now of
you the average person didn't stop the
video and then inspect these small 64 by
64 pixel image to determine whether it
was real or not I still think that's why
it was early it was a week afterwards
people figured out he did it and then
people were like whoa wait what we
didn't catch that so it's a combination
of it's like you can make the argument
that he made a fake photo and said this
is what Trump does and then say I was
making a gag it's another thing to put
three of them next to three real photos
and then tag it real life Trump and then
put sub to like put quoted text over it
so it's like harder to see but what's
the difference between that and like
making a meme like making a photo like
photoshopping something of somebody with
somebody like like let's say you know a
Photoshop picture of a candidate with
like Trump and Hillary I mean you don't
have to photoshop that because that's a
real thing but like people shouldn't
make fake things to trick other people
to gain political power
okay we spent way too much time on this
point
enjoyed it personally okay kpt M uh
Captain Marvel says question for Sheamus
isn't a visual portrayal of Christ a
violation of the first and second
commandment no no absolutely not I mean
he said he's the the visible face of the
invisible father that would not be a
violation of The Commandments also the
um so basically he's referring to first
and second commandments the way like
Protestants and Catholics number The Ten
Commandments is a bit different
so we we we consider like graven images
or idolatry to be lumped in with the
first commandment I'm not taking other
gods before him and it doesn't prohibit
you from having images of things and
especially not an image of God I don't
understand how that would even track
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and head
over to timcast.com click join us we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
show where many of you as members will
actually call in to talk to us and our
guest it's going to be a lot of fun so
again smash that like button you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Jamie
you want to shout anything out yes uh
you can follow me personally on Twitter
at the gay who strayed without an e at
the end and please follow gays against
groomers in the work we're doing on
Twitter it's against
grmrs still left over from the days you
couldn't say the word groomer on Twitter
yeah we had to change it and now the
other one's taken so
um and yeah just go to gaze
againstgroomers.com to learn more about
us or support our fight
my name is Seamus Coughlin I make
cartoons on a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we're going to be
releasing one tomorrow on the response
to sound of Freedom that we've seen from
the Hollywood establishment I think that
you guys are going to enjoy it it's
pretty spicy go over there uh like And
subscribe I will see you tomorrow God
bless and I'm Ian Crossland you guys
follow me Ian crossland.net really just
hit me up anywhere on Twitter Minds
YouTube Facebook Instagram wherever give
me a follow give me a like send me a
message if you want to I like to read
almost all of them if I can
um and uh someone mentioned that you
should start a drive-in theater I
thought that was kind of a cool
suggestion I missed those yeah those are
so great bring it back good Community
after every other project we're working
on yeah the 100th coffee shop stick it
in the queue have a nice evening
everyone
yeah likewise I Echo that have a nice
evening if you haven't seen the film
sound of Freedom I'm gonna go see it
maybe I'll try and get Sheamus on a date
we'll see if he'll do it we'll hang out
bro we'll definitely go to see the movie
when are you gonna go see it we can we
can figure it out I'll see if I'm if I'm
available but I'd totally be down well
now that I know again I would like to
maybe see you tomorrow but I don't know
if that'll happen I got I got a busy day
tomorrow we'll see anyways I'm
search.com let's get to the after show
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in a couple minutes thanks for hanging
up